Five four,
three,
two.
That countdown gives me anxiety.
I got to stop doing the countdown.
See,
look,
I spilled my fucking Alpha brain.
God Damn it.
What is Alpha brain?
It's a brain juice.
It's like a cognitive enhancing
supplement.
Really?
Yeah.
You ever fuck with nootropics?
You know what nootropics are?
No.
Do you have an extra one?
For sure.
Nootropics are essentially the building
blocks for human neurotransmitters.
They improve your memory not to
radically,
not like a,
have you ever fucked with modafinil or
any of that stuff?
No.
No,
no.
Modafinil is like a pro vigil.
It's um,
they give it to a fighter pilot.
Yeah.
I'm talking about it helps keep them
awake.
Oh,
it was a doctor.
So yeah.
You have a doctor?
My wife,
my wife is a doctor.
Oh,
your wife's a doctor.
that's perfect.
So she knows about all that jazz.
Um,
but there was just an article recently
about it.
Improving cognitive performance.
You're going to probably have to bite
into that.
You got it?
Yup.
Um,
it's good to meet you,
man.
I've opened it.
I've been a fan forever.
Thank you.
Me Too.
Looking forward.
Uh,
I've enjoyed your writing for sure.
And,
uh,
did you get that?
You got there?
I don't know.
Do I have to buy this?
Here we go.
Here we get scissors.
Jamie's get scissors for you if you
don't want to fuck with that.
I got it.
Here we go.
Um,
so let's talk about what we were just
talking about.
You were,
you wrote a book with a guy about drug
dealing and he was gonna come on wearing
a mask.
He wanted to come on wearing a,
a Barack Obama mask.
Actually.
Uh,
it's
really,
really funny.
The whole story is really fun.
I'm writing this book.
Um,
oh,
I spelled it too.
Um,
it's called the business secrets of drug
dealing.
Uh,
you can find
that@businesssecretsofdrugdealing.com.
Um,
and I'm serializing it,
uh,
but basically,
somebody I knew for ages,
um,
in a completely different capacity,
uh,
sort of came out to me last year and
said,
um,
you know,
I've been a high level of drug dealer
for,
for a long time,
basically my whole life.
And wanted to tell a story about,
uh,
you know,
sort of the,
the whole progression of his life.
What kind of drugs,
uh,
only things that grow out of the ground.
So,
uh,
he started off,
um,
this is,
uh,
this is an African American guy.
Uh,
he started off bleed or not selling
mushrooms.
Uh,
he,
he sort of grew up half in the projects
and half and in an upscale suburb.
Uh,
and he in the upscale suburb,
he sold mushrooms,
which he,
um,
uh,
basically got through mail order at a
time early in the sort of history of the
Internet when there were some loopholes
about things you get spores,
right?
Yeah.
Well actually you could get the actual
railing.
Yeah.
Um,
so he ends up having this whole career.
Uh,
uh,
and he wanted to,
to sort of explain to me what the rules
of the game where,
uh,
and do sort of a book version of the 10
Crack Commandments.
Uh,
and so we sat down and,
um,
we couldn't quite figure out how to do
it at first,
but we ended up essentially doing a sort
of fictionalized version of,
uh,
of his life.
Um,
and the progression is amazing because
he,
he goes from being a dealer in all these
different parts of the country in
different social spheres.
He's in college,
he deals to rich,
white kids.
He deals on the street and,
and,
you know,
tough urban neighborhoods and then ends
up sort of in the legal business,
uh,
in this state,
and lawyer,
no,
no.
He legal marijuana.
Oh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Uh,
and so he's describing that world,
which is not,
um,
there are a lot of misconceptions about
it.
Uh,
there are,
there are some things about it that are,
um,
not known terribly well.
Like,
you know,
what do you do when you work,
uh,
you know,
at a,
at a farm and,
uh,
your crop test dirty,
you know,
with a,
with a contaminant.
Um,
well,
you know,
not everybody just throws it away,
a lot of that stuff ends up shipped
across country,
goes to other markets.
Uh,
and he sort of describes a lot of this,
like what kind of contaminants would
that be?
Like fungal or past to like a,
like a,
like a fungus,
uh,
something like that.
Uh,
then,
you know,
there are labs that basically have to
clear,
uh,
you know,
from what I understand,
um,
that have to clear each of the crops.
And,
uh,
and there are situations where,
you know,
there's a whole bunch of crop and you've
got workers that have to be paid and
what do you do with it?
And the legal market isn't big enough,
um,
to accommodate all this stuff that's
grown.
And so there's sort of still,
you know,
kind of a black market that goes on.
And He,
he,
he describes this.
And,
uh,
but even before that,
it's just a fascinating book about,
you know,
all the different things that he learned
in the course of his career about how to
get it,
you know,
um,
do the job and not get caught.
Had A,
had a rig,
a load at to drive cross country.
How do you do a dummy car?
Um,
you know,
he tells a story about how basically you
want four cars,
you want the guy in the front seat to
be,
to be,
to look like a drug dealer,
have a terrible record,
drive badly,
uh,
basically to attract the police.
Uh,
and the,
you know,
the third car is the load car,
the second car sort of watching to see
if there's,
there's cops in either direction.
And then the fourth car is basically
driving up,
uh,
behind the load card to sort of prevent
anybody from seeing the license plate
and that sort of thing.
And so he just talks about all this
stuff and it's,
it's,
it's fascinating.
And,
um,
it was a new kind of writing for me
because I'd never really done anything
except straight journalism and we sort
of had to do it in narrative form.
And so we're,
we're putting it out serially online
right now,
which is really cool.
So you did one of those change the names
to protect the innocent.
Exactly,
yeah,
yeah.
Or,
or the guilty.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But for the most part based on facts,
yes,
yes.
The situations where let's just say
realistic,
you know?
Yeah.
And,
and his,
you know,
the observations were that,
uh,
that he describes are all,
you know,
things that he actually learned.
The situations were,
you know,
relatively close to things that actually
happened.
So yeah.
That's interesting.
So that's available now.
Yup.
Again,
it's uh,
uh,
business secrets of drug dealing.com.
It's,
it's the kind of a new thing.
Aye.
I,
I grew up,
I'm a huge fan of a serialized,
uh,
detective stories.
I was a big fan of like Dashiell
Hammett,
Raymond Chandler,
and I loved a black mask magazine,
which was the big pulp,
new our magazine and the twenties and
thirties.
And,
um,
you know,
I grew up reading all those stories and
I always,
uh,
it was in the back of my mind always
that I wanted to try this a and write a
book,
uh,
on a deadline.
So I'm doing this now.
It's a,
it's basically co written with this,
uh,
anonymous character who can appear with
me on shows like this anywhere because
he asks he's,
he's still not captured.
And,
um,
so it was their,
their warrants out for this guy.
No,
he's never been picked up and arrested.
Never been arrested?
Nope.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
it's like a smart dude.
He is a smart dude.
He has a smart dude and some of his
employers would be very surprised to
know that he's got a hobby like this.
Um,
uh,
it's funny.
I,
you know,
I knew him again.
I knew him for years and didn't have the
faintest clue,
uh,
that,
that this was,
this was going on.
So keep a job in order to avoid
suspicion.
So the book is actually structured with
all these rules.
It's chapter has,
has rules.
And at one of his,
his most important rules is always have
a job.
Uh,
and he,
it's for a number of reasons.
Number one,
um,
he talks about how when he was young,
he worked at places like,
you know,
Merriot or applebee's and he's like,
if you can serve,
um,
have the patients to serve people at an
apple bees and not blow up and scream
people,
then you won't screw up a package like
that.
In other words,
if you can have the self discipline to
actually get through one of these jobs
and not blow up and be crazy,
then you're going to handle or hinder
yourself well at a car stop.
That's fascinating.
So he used it almost like as a
discipline exercise.
He used it as a discipline exercise.
He learned among other things like,
uh,
another one for his rules,
his dress like an off duty is apple
piece waiter,
right?
Like,
do not dress.
Uh,
and he talks about this,
about how most dealers,
um,
they learn their,
their,
uh,
profession,
by watching movies.
You know,
there's no,
there's no book out there.
I mean,
it's not like this generation is growing
up reading like new the old iceberg slam
or Donald Goines novels or whatever it
is.
They're watching,
you know,
the wire or blow a or ozar canal or
whatever it is.
Um,
but dealers very often dress like
dealers.
You can,
you can kind of spot them,
you know,
and he says,
that's exactly the opposite of what you
have to do.
Um,
you know,
where sperry shoes were boring clothes
look like,
you know,
you've,
you're on your way to,
to,
you know,
your freshman English class or whatever
it is.
Um,
and you know,
sad sound like a nerdy college kid when,
when,
uh,
the cops pull you over and all this
stuff is a,
is sort of central to his,
his whole a worldview about how to avoid
getting caught.
Wow.
That would be a great book.
[inaudible] I mean,
it is,
it's,
it's really fun.
And you know,
the,
the fact that,
um,
that the,
you know,
the coauthor is actually a person who's
pulling this off makes it,
makes it really interesting and it makes
it a,
a real challenge to write it too,
because,
um,
you know,
I had to kind of,
uh,
simulate his voice,
and kind of communicate to people what,
what those situations were like and what
things look like from his point of view.
And obviously I'm white and he's African
American and that's,
that's tough.
And,
uh,
but you know,
I think it works,
it's kind of a cool story,
but it must've been a juicy,
like when you found the subject and just
felt like,
oh boy,
we got something here.
Oh yes.
Super Juicy.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's so much fun.
I haven't had this much fun,
like fun,
fun writing anything for,
for a long time because,
um,
you know,
most,
most criminal memoirs,
and again,
I grew up a junkie in terms of reading
the stuff I love.
I love books that are written after the
fact by people who were in crime.
You know,
like pappy on was one of my favorite
books growing up.
I mean,
it's a,
it's an amazing story about not,
not just crime,
but about prison and what's that like,
but they're always written by people
after they got caught.
Right.
And so there's never that book by the
person who's still out there,
uh,
and,
and talking about what al all life was
like,
um,
successfully,
uh,
still on the other side of the law.
And that,
that part of it is fascinating.
It's just a,
it's a completely new thing.
And,
and he has all these insights that I,
that I would never have thought about.
Like he,
he talks about how,
um,
there's a thing he calls the hood price.
Like if you,
when you're dealing,
uh,
selling to,
um,
uh,
in black neighborhoods even he charges a
higher price.
Uh,
because there's more,
there are more problems that you
inevitably run into when you're dealing
in those neighborhoods because there's
more cops,
which means more lawyers,
which means more security,
which means more attention to detail
when you deal to the rich white kids
just as nobody is paying attention.
So you just,
there's less overhead,
you know,
in the business.
Uh,
which is,
which is fascinating.
It's,
it's a,
and you know,
he talks to all about this and,
and he,
he has,
he spent a lifetime kind of just keeping
all this stuff in his head,
always wanting to,
to put it down and he just got to be too
much.
And he just sort of tapped me on the
shoulder one day and said,
can we have lunch?
I just want to talk to you about
something.
Do you know him before this?
I would say three years.
Four years.
Yeah.
We had a trust.
You well,
I'm glad we decided to not have him on
because he would get busted.
Yeah,
exactly.
They had talked to him.
Yeah.
Like you can't,
like if you were on something and you
had a mask on,
people go,
that's mad tie,
eat.
You know what I mean?
There'd be somebody listening to him.
He does.
Maybe he doesn't understand that there's
millions of people listening.
I totally agree with you.
Words of those people would go,
that's whatever,
right.
It's Mike.
That's John.
Whatever his name is.
They would get it.
Even the,
even the unabomber got caught and he
only talked to like two people,
you know,
especially today with this jeff
sessions,
mother fucker and Oh my God,
place.
He's scary.
You just see the shit that he's saying
now that they're going to actively
separate parents from their children if
they catch illegals coming over with
their families.
I mean that's just been dictative and
evil.
Yeah,
no,
and it's funny,
I covered trump obviously one on,
on the campaign trail and I watched,
uh,
the sort of the progression of his
thought,
uh,
or non thought as a,
as,
as it is,
uh,
on,
on things like immigration.
And it seemed to me that he could,
and very quickly that people just want
to be mean to inward immigrants.
He just,
it's not so much about the policy.
He was very nonspecific about that
whenever he could be.
He just wanted to say things that,
that,
that um,
feel vindictive and cruel and nasty.
And so doing something to is just,
it's just monstrous,
you know?
But SEF sessions is a real creep.
Oh,
he's horrible.
He's a scary guy.
Like,
one of the things that he said is good
people don't smoke marijuana.
Just saying that alone.
Do you know how many grandmas out there
with cancer are smoking marijuana?
Of course,
you know,
fuck you.
Right.
Crazy asshole.
Is the fact that someone could be in
such a position of influence and say
something like that.
Right?
Like this isn't just your dad saying
that good people don't smoke marijuana.
He goes out in the yard and fucking
smokes a cigarette.
This is,
this is the attorney general.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're fine.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
when you take ignorance and then the
full weight of the executive branch,
um,
Eh,
you know,
especially the d,
the anti-drug apparatus,
you know,
that's,
that's a terrible,
terrible combination with it.
And it's too bad because I think,
I think even the law enforcement
community was kind of coming around on
this.
Yes.
Um,
you know,
they,
they don't want to be picking up people
for dealing weed.
I mean,
I talked to from my last book about the
Eric Garner case,
I talked to lots of cops and they,
they just hate having to do that.
You know,
those,
those buses are not fun for them.
Well,
the Eric Gardner case was the guy who
got choked in New York,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Cigarettes,
which has even even more than doubles.
Yeah.
And that's,
and you know,
cops having to do that,
that's not even a misdemeanor in New
York.
And you know,
if you gotta,
if you got to drag somebody in for
selling a 50 cents cigarette,
you know,
that's not exactly serpico.
You know what I mean?
Like again,
a cops don't,
you don't join the force dreaming of
doing that.
So,
but uh,
yeah,
I mean the sessions thing is terrible.
Yeah.
Having that guy in that kind of a
position and saying things like,
good people don't smoke marijuana or,
you know,
when families come across the border
illegally,
we're going to separate the parents from
the children.
Like,
the fuck is wrong with you.
And then you throw in a good dose of the
Jesus Jesus.
Yeah,
exactly.
Scary fucking time.
At least trump has said that he's going
to,
he's not going to support sessions on
going after marijuana in states where
it's legal is going to leave the states
to take care of it themselves.
That's encouraging the,
the,
the problem with Donald Trump and,
and this is something that I didn't clue
into until I'd spent a lot of time
watching the guy and following them
around,
is that he can sound like he believes
something very deeply and you can be
absolutely convinced that he even,
uh,
logically thanks,
thanks a thing.
But he'll have a meeting with somebody
and five minutes later I'll have a
completely the opposite opinion.
So I have no confidence that Donald
Trump will anything that he says that
he,
that it will stay his opinion on
anything.
He can be convinced to go through a
complete one 80 on basically any issue,
which is scary,
isn't he in some ways the perfect
representative of America because of
that.
Absolutely.
He has no attention span.
And,
and,
and I talked about this when,
when I was covering him because people
said,
oh,
what,
what is this billionaire in New York or
have in common with,
with an ordinary Americans?
He has a lot in common with them.
He has exactly the same media habits
that they have.
He reads the same dumb shit on the
Internet.
Um,
he has the same total inability to
separate fact from fiction.
Uh,
he's completely credulous when he reads
a news item about something that he
personally agrees with,
uh,
and he'll,
he'll tweet it out five seconds later
before he checks it out,
which is like what every other American
does.
You know,
they get something on facebook and they
immediately share it with,
you know,
all their friends.
Um,
and this is a,
this is an American thing now.
And just the total inability to,
to logically look at things,
I don't know.
Yeah.
And the short attention span too,
short attention span,
drifting in and out of conversations,
not being able to pay attention to memos
unless his name is in there.
Oh,
a hundred times.
Yeah,
exactly.
People,
I know.
It sounds like American.
Right,
right.
And,
and you know,
it's,
it's funny because if you,
if you watch trump speeches are actually
better or better yet,
if you read trump's speeches,
it's,
they would pass out,
um,
the text of what trump was supposed to
say,
uh,
before his events.
And so I'd be sitting there,
I'd be looking at the,
the,
the remarks,
and they would be cogent from one end to
the other.
Then he would get up there and the first
line we'd be like,
oh,
it's so great to be back in Manchester,
New Hampshire.
I always loved,
you know,
being here.
And that would be right.
And then he would veer off and he would,
he would start saying one thing and then
the other thing and his thoughts would
drift and all these different
directions.
And then when you looked at the actual
transcript of what Donald Trump had
said,
he not only wasn't completing thoughts,
he wasn't completing sentences.
He talks in these sort of strange
fragments.
Uh,
and he'll,
he'll drift from one idea to another and
they won't have any logical connection
to each other.
And people still responded to it,
which tells you something both about him
and about his audience.
Right.
Because they're on the same weird mental
wave length where we're just sort of
disconnected bits of of emotion and
thought is enough now.
Right.
Isn't that weird?
I mean that is where it's really strong.
Strange.
Well,
people don't know that someone's not
smart if they're dumber than the person.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I think what it's revealing is what a
small amount of time most people spend
actually thinking,
thinking about ideas,
thinking about themselves,
thinking about behavior,
thinking about the impact that someone
who's in the position of president can
have.
Very few people are out there actually
thinking.
Yeah,
I mean relatively a pretty large number
overall,
but very few in terms of percentages,
in terms of the people that you can
reach and the people that will show up
at his press rallies.
That's a big thing too.
Right?
Who the fuck
is going to go to a campaign speech for
anybody unless you're a journalist.
Well that's,
that's interesting because I've,
I've been to a million campaign rallies,
right.
And,
and my opinion on them is,
you know,
I would rather basically stick a
railroad spike in my ear then then
voluntarily go to one of these things.
Um,
and not,
you know,
not be paid to do it because normally a
campaign speeches like this
supernaturally boring experience where a
guy or you know,
a woman stands up there and reads out a
preselected,
a market tested list of political
cliches that,
um,
have no meaning whatsoever and that,
you know,
don't represent what they're actually
going to do in,
in when there are an office.
Anyway.
Um,
so,
and if you have to listen to that 40 or
50 times in a row,
which is what happens when you're
covering campaigns,
like you want to kill yourself.
So why anyone would go voluntarily to,
to,
to see that as entertainment is sort of
beyond me.
But that happened in,
in 2015 and 2016 trumps events were a
little different.
They were,
um,
they were a little bit,
and I think he got a little bit of this
from his wwe experience.
Like he turned them into these kind of
menacing,
weird,
uh,
audience participation,
things where he would have the audience
turn on the press and shout at us and
throw things.
And,
you know,
we,
because we're always standing up on
those risers,
uh,
and we have ropes around us.
We look like zoo animals or something.
And,
uh,
and we were the representatives and they
hated the lead,
you know,
and,
and he'll it,
and he turned it into this sort of like,
physical,
menacing,
intimate thing.
And,
you know,
people would come from all over.
They'd come from down the hills,
you know,
and drive 50 miles to,
to,
to see the spectacle.
It was,
it was fascinating to watch,
but kind of terrifying too.
Well,
the peep.
Yeah.
The people that are going to those
things,
like,
boy,
that has an odd group of humans that
have decided this is how you're going to
spend your day.
You're going to go watch this guy rabble
about fake news,
right.
He's going to ramble about this.
You're fake news and point.
The CNN guy,
you're a fake news.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Fake News.
CNN.
Terrible,
terrible rating.
And people like this Yas,
they wave the flag,
keep going,
say things that make me feel good,
say things that excite me.
Absolutely.
And Yeah.
You know,
look at these blood suckers.
That was a line that he,
that he used to pull out a lot.
Look at these bloodsuckers,
these people reporting information.
Yeah.
We speak again,
we'd be sitting there and a whole bunch
of reporters and we're,
we're a bunch of geeks and aero shirts.
You know,
we got the,
we got pads and we're kind of looked
very surrounded by,
you know,
in some cases,
15,000 people who,
you know,
are kind of turning in our direction.
And um,
you know,
in a couple of cases at it,
there were,
it was definitely up in the air whether
this was going to turn ugly or,
and in a few places that did turn ugly
and,
and um,
but he,
he,
he was very clued in.
The one thing I will say about trump is
that he has a,
a keen instinct for audience.
He knows where they are.
He knows what their mood is.
He knows what he has to do to get them,
um,
you know,
to wake them up,
uh,
to,
to stir them up.
He can tell when he's losing them.
Um,
uh,
I mean that,
that is,
that is one talent that he does have.
Uh,
but it's,
it's a negative talent for sure.
Well,
he uses it certainly in a negative way.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
w how much attention have you paid it
all to his use of diet pills had been
following that at all.
No,
that's fascinating.
What is he using?
A lot of diet pills.
I'm so glad I could talk to matt tight.
This is great.
What was the reporter was at Washington
Post that first talked about it.
They found the Duane Reed pharmacy where
he was first prescribed diet pills by
this doctor who described it for a
nonexistent condition,
like metabolic deficiency or some shit
like metabolic disorder,
I think he called it,
and it allowed him to prescribe in.
This guy was like a known prescriber of
these things,
like a doctor feel a good time and he's
got it.
He's got you covered.
Yay.
Metabolic disease.
So Matt,
you're gonna feel peppy all day and he's
supposed to be on these for a very short
amount of time.
He was on them for a long period of
time.
And I'm this guy,
this reporter to printed out,
tweeted out the actual Duane Reed
pharmacy where trump was filling this
prescription.
And then now they,
they're saying that he's on some other
diet pill,
which is one of the ingredients that was
in phen.
Phen do you remember Phen Phen Oh,
absolutely.
Unfortunately I know.
Yeah.
Phen phen was something for,
people don't know that the young folks
out there,
there was a pill that people were taking
in the 1990s and I knew a gal who was a
very pretty girl,
but she was large and she got on the fen
phen and I hadn't seen her in like,
I dunno,
like six months or something.
And I saw her and all of a sudden she
was like 120 pounds.
So I was like,
what?
You look amazing.
Like what are you doing?
Like you exercise and it's not that,
did you go crazy and join a gym?
And he's like,
no.
I started taking this stuff called phen
phen and she'd be like,
Blah Blah Blah.
Couldn't stop talking and grinding his
teeth a little bit,
non speed and she started having weird
feelings with her heart.
So she stopped it and it turns out
people are just dropping dead left and
right off of this stuff.
I'm going to give you a fucking heart
attacks and all kinds of shit is
hardcore stuff.
But they recognize that the combination
of these two things was the issue.
But one of these things by themselves
is,
okay,
so this one by itself is what they think
he's on now,
which makes sense that a guy who's in
his seventies has so much energy.
I mean they say he's up at five o'clock
in the morning watching Fox News and
then he starts tweeting like a five 30
in the morning.
He's tweeting and gets very little
sleep.
You drinks like 12 diet cokes a day.
I mean the guy's just,
he's got boundless energy.
Like when he was campaigning,
that was the thing that was so stunning
to me.
I was like,
I know what it's like to go on the road
and just do stand up.
Just to stand up where you have your
act.
You fuck around.
It's fun.
You have a good time is fucking,
whereas you add after a couple of days,
oh yeah.
One town and the next town.
By the time that third day rolls around,
you're fucking beat down.
This guy was doing day after day after
day after day.
And he's like,
good.
It's all great to see all you wonderful
people.
We're going to make America great again.
The wall got 10 feet higher and
everything is with energy.
And,
and this is the speculation,
the speculation.
Is he like,
I mean,
I'm sure you're aware many,
many journalists are on adderall,
right?
He's on something.
Sure.
Yeah.
No,
of course.
This is in my,
like the way I look at it,
it's like this is indicative of where
America stands today.
It's not just that he's a good
representative of mayor because he has
the same media consumption habits and
the same,
uh,
inability to read books and all these
different variables,
but also because he's pilled up,
right?
Which is everybody in America,
everybody in America,
right?
I mean,
that's
like there,
there's,
there's a little bit of a precedent
there because,
um,
uh,
you know,
Kennedy had so many physical problems
that,
uh,
I'm not sure if you remember,
there was a book that dark side of
camelot that came and came out by Sy
Hersh,
uh,
where,
it talked about how Kennedy in the
morning used to have an s a secret
service agent give him,
uh,
a shot of basically amphetamines every,
every morning.
And he would sort of pace around the
oval office talking about who we wanted
to whack today.
You know,
this,
this was like the background for Bay of
Pigs and you know,
all these other things.
Um,
so it's very dangerous when a president
is,
you know,
pharmaceutically altered when a person
who,
uh,
is,
you know,
if he's,
if he's on speed and he's tweeting
threats to a nuclear power,
like a,
I mean that would be a very ironic and
uh,
but terrible way for all of it.
All of that,
all of us to end
find the tweet I've been looking for.
It was hard to find the first time.
I know who wrote it,
but I can't you gotta you gotta save
that and put it in your favorites cause
we talked about it so many times.
You got to figure out a way to save that
and put it in a bookmark because it was
in like he had the Duane Reed pharmacy
and then there's the speculation about
what the most recent stuff is that he's
on,
which is again,
one ingredient in fen phen.
But one of the things that they were
saying is that when you look at the side
effects of this stuff,
one of the side effects is a delusional
of reality.
Delusions of grandeur,
of course,
aggression,
impulsiveness,
like all these things that we associate
with Donald Trump.
Like we,
we don't even know who he is.
We know.
We know who he is.
Pilled up if this guy's right,
which is fucking fascinating.
He might be dealing with essentially a
pharmaceutical intervention into not
just American lives in terms of
individuals,
but in terms of the way policy is driven
and the way the country moves forward.
It might literally be pharmaceutically
enhanced,
that's very Philip k Dick,
but it could easily be true,
could easily be true.
It all seems true.
It seems like,
like I'm not saying anything that's
outland as first of all not,
we're talking about something that's
real pills.
These pills are real.
We're talking about something that's
widely consumed.
Everybody knows this and we're talking
about a guy who was an extraordinary,
extraordinary amount of energy for
somebody who doesn't work dirt work out,
rather doesn't eat healthy.
Right.
And like what?
Where's he getting on his energy?
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I remember talking about this with some
of the other reporters because
as you say,
the campaign trail is incredibly
grueling.
There's a reason why some candidates
can't do it.
Um,
or,
or they opt to do lots of legacy media
appearances or ad buys.
They,
they travel less than a pure more.
The people who tend to succeed are the
ones who can do three or four
appearances a day,
fly to three different cities a day.
Um,
and they,
most of those people are either health
freaks,
people who are,
you know,
in good physical condition.
Obama was,
was definitely one of those people who,
who,
you know,
had to have a run at some point or else
he couldn't do that schedule.
But Donald Trump,
you know,
you look at him and it's kind of
history.
There it is.
Fun fact,
in 19 to trump started taking
amphetamine derivatives,
abused them,
only supposed to take two for 25 days,
stayed on for eight years.
Really?
And this is Kurt [inaudible] White House
submit,
uh,
admitted it to me,
said only a short time for diet in
quotes when he was not overweight.
I countered with medical records.
They cut me off.
People misreading drug was dye,
ethyl [inaudible] 75 milligrams a day
prescription filled at Duane reed on
57th street in Manhattan.
Oh,
I know.
I know things,
doctor who,
uh,
wrote prescription Dr. Joseph Greenberg
diagnosed him with metabolic imbalance,
which we have never heard about.
Again.
Greenberg was later publicly slammed as
someone who provided uppers to rich
people in Manhattan,
a metabolic imbalance in quotes.
Uh,
if true could be electrolyte
insufficiencies anaerobic and bounces
acid and bounces and an assortment of
related disorders that can have serious
health consequences.
Yet his other doctor,
Dr Harold Bornstein said he had been
trump's doctors since 1980 and it never
mentioned the metabolic imbalance found
by Greenburg.
Yeah,
right,
right.
So save that,
save that in book.
Barkat now find out what the other
stuff,
cause he was in just to just google
trump is on one of the ingredients in
phen.
Phen so I googled that.
That came up and like a gawker article,
excuse me.
Gawker Gawker are call Walker from 2016
that said he was on fincher,
but at the actual name of venture mean
or,
yeah.
Um,
so this is what they think he's on now.
Fincher mean yes.
Which is also a stimulant,
which just makes sense.
If that guy's telling the truth of Kurt
icon wall is telling the truth,
that means that he was on pills,
amphetamines for eight years,
which means he is having good results.
So if he was looking at this room or a
doctor prescribes Donald Trump cheap
speed,
and this is a Ashley,
what is her name?
Ashley Fineburg.
Ashley Fineberg.
Who is a really good reporter.
Well,
I'm sure she's right.
It makes fucking makes sense.
Absolutely.
It makes sense.
I mean everybody,
you know,
I don't know how a person whose diet is
cheeseburgers and that coke could run
for president
without tried chicken with a fork and
knife.
Weirdo.
See that?
No,
I've never seen that on the trump jet
eaten fried chicken with a fork and
knife alone.
She'd be like,
who are you fucking alien in a trump
suit?
So I wouldn't know that because they
keep the press in a separate plane.
Oh yeah,
there you go.
That is,
oh my God,
look at the bucket.
Yeah.
Eating fried chicken with a fork and
knife.
See,
that's bad.
I mean,
I think I would think ordinary America
would,
would dig him for that because let's use
your fingers.
Fingers.
Just put your face in it
if you have to.
Yeah.
You doing man?
Fork and knife.
Fried Chicken.
You got him elitist.
Amazing.
Phen phen was that,
well,
even the,
um,
was the name of the very cheap speed
that used to be imported when I lived in
Russia,
they,
there was,
there was a type of speed that used to
come from the Baltics,
um,
that allegedly,
uh,
you know,
the,
the urban legend was,
was that the Nazis had all their
soldiers on a cheap speed for the long
marches going into,
into Russia.
And they set up these,
uh,
these pharmaceutical plants,
and theory.
And again,
the street legend was that,
that was what this drug was,
but they called it fen.
So,
uh,
wasn't
that the original,
the origins of methamphetamines wasn't
methamphetamines created by the Nazis?
I believe it was.
And I think this is one of the
speculations as to why they could get
suicide bombers.
The kamikazes to slam their jets into
aircraft carriers,
loaded them up on math up.
Right.
Well we have those go pills.
Right?
That's what they're called.
Is it?
Well,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
there's definitely some speed that gets
prescribed and steroids right.
Also to soldiers.
Um,
and maybe talk to people that have been
in,
you know,
they'll,
they'll tell you about what different
things that they allow them to take and
gave them to take.
But um,
that modafinil stuff is,
um,
that's really common.
And then I know,
I know a lot of fighter pilot or pilots
we'll take that keeps you from getting
sleepy,
keeps you alert and awake.
And that was also something Hillary
Clinton was supposed to be on.
Really?
Yeah.
She was supposed to be on Modafinil.
That was one of the things that she
admitted to.
Um,
and it's legal and it's done.
It's a weird,
if you've tried that now,
it's a weird one.
It doesn't speed you up in terms of like
heart rate.
It's not like,
like drinking five cups of coffee,
but it does give you this weird sense of
alertness like,
oh,
fucking really awake.
That sounds kind of good.
It's kind of good.
Yeah.
I have a buddy of mine who's a writer
who,
uh,
he's got some health issues and he,
he's on it all the time and he said,
if I don't take it,
I'm a mess.
I just really,
yeah.
Well,
I mean a slim,
it sounds,
sounds perfect for writers.
So look at that photo and add,
stay fit and slim by,
by taking him fed.
I mean,
look at her.
She looks happy.
She looks really happy.
Super happy.
Now they should have the next day
picture how she's dead.
Dead for decades.
He died a day after they took that
picture.
What does this one tons of them more
dean.
She can now she can cook breakfast
again.
When you prescribed new Morn Dean
Morton,
Morton and dean worn a dean.
What is more than a deed?
It's you take it in the morning,
you wakes you up.
Well,
she can make breakfast again.
Thanks honey.
If I keep bouncing off the world.
Yeah.
She's going to put a line on the,
on that spatula after,
uh,
after she's done and just,
yeah,
that's great.
Yeah,
there was,
um,
I think there was a time where people
didn't understand how bad that stuff was
for you.
And this was probably a lot of people on
it,
right?
I don't know,
but probably going through a similar
period where all kinds of stuff is being
prescribed that we're gonna find out 50
years from now.
Like,
Oh really?
They're like,
we prescribed adderall to 50 million
children or whatever it was.
I'm sure.
Like it's just kind of sea monsters I
think.
Sure.
Something Someday Prozac,
adderall.
And then the numbers of Ssri is that are
prescribed needlessly.
Like who knows how many people actually
need those things versus how many people
were just having a bad day and went to
the doctor and they give you something
numbs you up.
Right,
right.
And how many,
how many schools are,
are mandated to,
you know,
to put,
bunch of kids on,
on these drugs.
I,
I think probably in hindsight,
some of that is going to look really bad
for sure.
I mean,
we're experimenting,
experimenting on People's brains and
absolutely these pharmaceutical
companies have billions of dollars in
massive influence and they're making it
so this stuff
is okay.
Maybe just had a look at the number of
people that are dying just dying from
opiate pills.
Right.
If those were illegal drugs,
we'd be saying that there's a,
there's two goddamn epidemic.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
But they,
uh,
there's no question that it's a
conscious strategy to get people hooked
and,
and get them taking those pills for in
every conceivable scenario so that they
will seek them out in other areas,
not in legally.
Um,
I think,
uh,
but some,
some prosecutor is going to have to
figure out some way to get to hold some
of those companies accountable because
they're definitely doing not on purpose,
but even if they do,
it seems like they just,
it's like the tobacco thing,
they get paid,
right.
You know,
they pay off a few billion dollars,
it's barely scratches at debt and then
they write it all off.
Jack up the price of everything a little
bit over the course of 10 years of
balances itself out to zero.
Right,
right,
right.
A couple of movies will be made,
but at the same thing will happen going
forward.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Like that Russell Crowe movie the
insider.
Yeah,
that was great.
it was a good movie.
It was a good movie.
It was actually kind of more movie
about,
about the death of the press as it
turned out than it was a movie about the
death of the tobacco industry.
But um,
yeah,
it was,
it was really interesting.
Um,
what is it like being a reporter and
being a journalist rather today with all
this fake news talk like this?
This is a new thing,
this whole calling something fake news.
There's certainly is manufactured
stories and things that just aren't
true.
Websites that are just designed to get
people to click on them and they have
crazy stories that didn't really happen,
but they're pretty obvious.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think a lot of what people call
fake news is just news that is very
heavily slanted in one direction.
And you know,
people,
people talk a lot about how fox is fake
fake news.
Well,
most of the time when you watch Fox,
what they're just doing is they're
selectively picking out stories that
they know are going to rile up their
elderly,
a freaked out,
terrified audience,
you know,
and so they pick out the four or five
things that are,
that actually happened around the world.
They,
they can do that without lying.
You know,
they don't,
they don't have to make this stuff up.
They can find the,
the lineup of facts that they want.
Um,
but you know,
uh,
working as a journalist now is,
is,
um,
very,
very different.
The business is undergoing a extremely
rapid change and it's not something that
we really,
um,
have reckoned with.
We haven't sat down and had a discussion
about where this is all going and,
uh,
how we can fix it because,
um,
the business is changing in a way that
is extremely negative and no one's
talking about how to,
how to reverse that.
Like long form investigative reporting
is started to disappear,
uh,
in the 80s,
but it's accelerated to the point
where there's almost none of that now.
Almost everybody who works in the
business is doing quick hits and there's
almost no time left to do,
you know,
kind of Real,
real hardcore investigative work.
And we've trained our audiences also to
be unable to consume that kind of stuff.
Um,
so,
you know,
we're,
we're all basically doing clickbait now
and,
and I think it's,
it's a really dark time in our business.
Well,
it's,
it's also this weird time of
transitioning between paper and digital
and trying to get people to pay for
digital.
I mean,
I subscribed to a few of them online,
a Washington Post New York Times where
you pay,
but I don't think very many people are
doing that.
I think it's probably a small amount of
people that are paying.
Right.
You know,
I think the New York Times gives you
like 10 articles a month or something
like that for free.
And then like,
come on,
man,
you're here every day.
Time to pay up.
You know,
they give you like a little countdown,
then you're like,
oh,
this is a good article.
All right,
I'm going to pay.
Yeah.
And this is,
this is a fascinating sort of sub plot
to what happened to the media business
because a lot of that is because of
something that Google did a long time
ago.
They had this thing called the first
click rule,
which is the sort of mandated that all
all new sites have at least some free
content or else the algorithm would,
would push the,
the,
uh,
new story far down on the search
results,
right?
So if you,
if you didn't have free content on your
site,
if you didn't meet Google's first click
rule,
uh,
when you search for a new story,
you just wouldn't find it.
So all of these,
um,
in the early days of sort of digital
journalism,
uh,
all the news companies offered their
content basically for free and,
uh,
that trained audiences to not pay for
journalism basically.
Uh,
and it's,
it's pretty hard to put the genie back
in the bottle and tell everybody to go
back and,
and pay for everything.
It just doesn't work that way.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we're,
we're in this place where everybody sort
of consuming free media and not only
that,
there's this additional problem of the,
you know,
the internet platforms like facebook and
Google,
um,
pushing news that they already know
people are going to agree with two
users.
So there's,
there's,
there's sort of less news that
challenges people,
uh,
they're just not going to see it,
you know,
because that's not the way the
algorithms work.
The algorithms are really confusing.
So the algorithms like will actively
pick out things they think you'll be
interested in.
So if you're someone who has got a
particular set of interest,
it,
it becomes sort of a,
an echo chamber,
right?
Your Google search becomes an echo
chamber.
You're go,
I have that Google News App on my phone.
I'll check it every morning,
see what's going,
but it's all shit that I'm interested
in.
Right,
right.
It's,
it's probably a little bit worse on
facebook than it is on Google,
but because it's google,
you at least have some,
some control over what you searched for.
But even Google will will prompt you
with things,
right?
Like so,
but with,
um,
with both of them,
yeah.
They,
they're,
they're accumulating lots and lots of
information about your,
not only about what you read but about
the things that you buy,
the movies that you watch,
what your predilections probably are and
what your opinions,
your political stances.
And so they pick out a new stories that
they think are,
are likely to endorse or spent a lot of
time reading.
Um,
which likely means that you're never
going to see a news story that says you
personally are responsible for something
bad.
Right.
That's like thing one,
uh,
you will see a lot of news stories that
say your neighbor is responsible for
something bad.
Uh,
and that's one of the reasons why like
divisiveness is a conscious commercial
strategy.
It's just,
it's,
it's a natural,
uh,
result of a lot of this,
a lot of these behaviors.
What is the mean age of people that are
watching Fox News?
You're talking about like how it's like
people 68.
Yeah,
it's,
it's something ridiculously all the,
and that's true of all the,
all the cable networks,
they're all MSNBC.
Yeah.
Even Msnbc,
um,
the,
you know,
it's,
it's worse with Fox and,
and uh,
and CNN and I don't want to,
I don't want to misquote it,
but I know they're all like above 65.
Um,
so
[inaudible] 68,
you're right.
Look at that median age of a prime time
at Fox News.
Do we do we have an MSAC 65,
the younguns CNN 60.
Oh,
they're little kids.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so a lot of that has to do with the
fact that young people just don't watch
television.
Right.
Like they,
they're done.
They're done.
So they're getting their news some other
way.
They're not getting it ready.
Well,
yeah,
they're night or they're not getting it
in youtube videos,
getting almost no news.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a post to,
like,
when I was a kid,
I mean,
what are the,
I used to deliver newspapers,
so I've read newspapers quite a bit.
Did you?
Yeah.
You want to do the globe?
Yeah,
I did until I was a paper boy.
Where was your route?
Ah,
let's see.
I had one in Hingham.
I had one in Norwell.
Wow.
Yeah,
I did mostly Newton.
Newton.
Okay.
Yeah,
I did the globe.
I did the,
um,
the Herald Boston Herald and I delivered
the New York Times for awhile.
But just so I didn't like the New York
Times is interesting because it wasn't,
didn't pay as well.
And there were a larger routes,
like you had to go much further because
there was very few houses that would get
the times right.
But you felt like you were doing
something special
liver and the New York Times that the
prestige to it and they had clear blue
plastic bags.
Oh Wow.
Is that a blue bag?
Like the Boston Globe at clear bags,
they deliver those in clear bags,
but the times the Herald should have
been in a brown paper bag,
like a,
like a porno or something like that.
Did they,
do they deliver like the Daily News and
the post in New York?
Does that get delivered or is it just,
yeah,
I mean they must,
um,
yeah,
they have,
they have subscriptions and then,
and the times is the daily news
definitely does have a delivery for
sure.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Yeah.
But,
but that I just spent a lot of time
writing about this.
The,
the VAT model where,
uh,
newspapers had this direct relationship
with their readers,
right?
Like they not only owned the content and
created the content,
but they also,
uh,
completely controlled the distribution.
Right?
They had the trucks,
they had the paper kids like us.
Right.
Um,
that was all part of what gave the press
it's power is that we were,
we had the unique ability to reach all
these people.
Well,
you know,
once the Internet came along,
they cut that in half.
Right?
So now the distribution is all google
and facebook,
uh,
and the content is all being made by
somebody else.
So it's um,
it,
it makes it very difficult to make
money,
uh,
a and then b you just don't have that,
that personal relationship with the,
with the,
the,
the consumer anymore,
which is,
which is a completely different sort of
paradigm.
I do you think there's a connection to
ponder this myself?
It seems like in the early days of the
Internet,
one a big factor with the music industry
for sure was napster.
Napster came along and then people got
this initial taste of getting a bunch of
stuff that you'd normally paid for,
for free,
get just get tons of it.
And then so the internet sort of got
associated with being a free thing and
then there was bit torrent and through
bit torrent you can get films and all
kinds of different stuff.
You could download movies and,
and people just start filling up hard
drives with this stuff that they would
get off a bit torrent.
And in my mind at least it became this
connection with the Internet.
Stuff's free.
There's so much stuff for free.
Like why would I pay for this?
Right.
And that's free.
And I've,
I've tried to say this to friends who
get involved with podcasting,
who have come over from radio,
like just friends that have been fired
from radio jobs.
Like,
you know what,
I'm just going to start a podcast and
charge people five bucks a month.
But as soon as you do that,
people are like,
why the fuck would I pay get Adam
Carolla for free?
Joey Diaz for free?
Why would I pay $5 for you?
Right.
Yeah,
absolutely know that the audience
expectations now or that they're going
to get free content,
everything's free,
everything's free.
And,
um,
obviously that has a
huge consequences because that forces
people who create the content to get the
money from somewhere else.
They either have to be sponsored by an
advertiser who might have certain
expectations.
Um,
but it,
you know,
it's certainly not good for the people
who,
who make content that,
that,
that it's like that.
Uh,
and,
and it creates,
I think,
a lot of bad habits with,
um,
with,
with the readers too.
I mean they,
they just,
you know,
rather than,
rather than look for the best stuff,
they just look for what's available and
what they can read for free.
Also,
I think it opens up the door to all this
wacky advertising where pop up ads and,
and scroll down ads.
Like you try to scroll down a screen and
the ad follows with you and then,
Oh God,
so annoying.
Right.
It's weird.
It's just,
it,
it's,
they're so invasive and they're
everywhere.
Even on really good websites.
Like,
like say if you go to CNN,
you get the real stories and then below
you get this stuff that looks like
stories.
But there's a very faint print,
it says paid content.
Right.
And then you look at it like you're not
going to believe what she looks like now
and then you click and you can't be
outbrain.
Yeah.
I can't even find out what she looks
like now cause you've got to go through
40 other people that look like shit now
too.
And then finally you get it.
Sometimes you don't even get to the
original one.
So you're confused.
I think it's better if they don't
satisfy you because then he'd just go
back to the rest of the site.
Well what does he look like?
You know,
you go to all these different,
there was like one of those pages that
you go to where there's just dozens and
dozens of windows and boxes that you can
click on different individual like
cliquey bait stories where you go to
each one of them and they'll take you to
40 pages of different people that have
gained weight or lost weight or a poor
now or whatever it is.
But that's,
I mean,
I think it's one of the things that's
really bad about that is that if you
spend enough time doing that,
your brain stops being able to do other
things.
You know,
like when you're reading books,
books require you to sit there and
construct in your head all the visuals
for everything that you're reading.
You have to imagine what the people look
like.
You have to,
you know,
do all this mental work to construct the
scene,
right?
So your brain is actively engaged in,
in this,
in this really highly specific.
And,
and creative way.
Right.
Um,
but the Internet now just has it moving
from place to place,
clicking from place to place,
going from sensation to sensation.
Um,
you don't have to ponder anything.
You don't have to have an opinion about
anything.
You don't have to look at both sides of
You just have to move from one thing to
another to the next thing,
which is what you're talking about with
trump.
That's the way his brain works.
Right?
Like,
and it's,
it's uh,
I think it's a bad thing,
you know,
it's not only bad in itself,
but it makes it impossible for us to do
the other thing,
you know,
which is,
which is more constructive.
Yeah.
No,
it's
almost like mental range of motion.
Like if you're somehow or another,
your joints were restricted where you
could only like move a certain amount
after a while,
you would lose your full range of
motion.
Absolutely.
It gets atrophied.
I have a heart,
I'm reading books now than I did when I
was,
you know,
probably 11 years old.
And,
and that's just from,
and you're a writer.
Write,
I'm a writer.
I mean,
I love,
I love it.
Yeah.
I still,
I find that I have a harder time doing
the work,
you know?
Yeah.
And that's difficult.
Or like when I was,
when I was younger,
I read more fiction,
which,
which is harder because it requires you
to do more,
you know,
sort of mental construction work.
Um,
now it's much,
if I'm going to read a book,
it's typically nonfiction,
which is linear,
which is an argument,
right?
It's,
it's,
um,
it's less,
it requires less work of the
[inaudible].
Right.
It may be just as interesting,
but it just requires less work.
Uh,
so like the hardest thing to read is,
you know,
Anna Karenina or something like that.
Right.
But you have to not only think,
but you have to construct,
but with your,
if you're just reading the diary of Kim
Kim,
Kim Kardashian or something like that,
you're just,
you're just kind of listening to
somebody,
you know,
go look like that.
So I think it's bad.
I think all of this stuff is negative,
but I dunno.
Maybe I'm an old fogy about it.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I definitely think it's not the most
ideal in terms of constructing a healthy
mind.
Right,
right.
But,
but it's what we got.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's weird.
It's so
weird time.
Absolutely.
And it's,
and you know,
there's,
there's lots of positive things.
The positive things are like that.
Anybody can have a voice now and anybody
who has something interesting to say can
be instantly elevated and have an
audience overnight.
And that's great.
Right?
Like,
you know,
the,
in the,
in the old days,
if you had to penetrate this ridiculous
oligarchy of entertainment,
people who,
who really own tightly controlled,
who got access to what,
who got to be,
you know,
have an audience a and now you get to
bypass that entirely and sort of
directly appeal to,
to,
to people,
which is great.
I mean,
that's an amazing thing.
But then you get youtube stars,
right?
Yeah,
exactly right.
Yeah.
I went down a little rabbit hole the
other day.
You fucking asshole.
Jamie told me about little town.
He would tell him a little day.
So I went down this crazy rabbit hole
and then I read this Jessebelle article
about another,
a rider who went down a little tay
rabbit hole,
and so I went down that rabbit hole.
Oh my God.
Wait,
who is a little tail?
Little Tay is a nine year old girl,
is famous now on the Internet for
talking Shit and showing all the money
she has and all the things she buys.
If you don't know about little tank,
no,
no.
This is the death of society.
Okay.
Little Tase.
The death of society.
Lil Lil tank.
Can we,
can we see that?
Yes,
for sure.
Oh,
the youngest of the flexor of the
century.
Who makes cash?
Me Outside.
Girl looked like a scholar.
She's fucking nine dude.
Okay.
I have a nine year old.
All right.
This is crazy.
Play played this video jamie so he can
understand what little taze all about.
That's her revenue per lamborghini.
She gets out.
Tell Him Jake,
just throwing money
at them when you're alive.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the next president of United States and
he's,
he's bound in the background.
I mean,
this is what we're doing.
What we're doing and this is what
society is doing.
This makes honey booboo and it's like
Marie Curie,
you know what I mean?
God Ram.
It's got 337,000 likes.
God dammit.
Jamie,
what have you done?
We all hear stunting on all y'all broke
ass haters.
500 K in cash.
And this lambo costs more than your
college tuition.
I'm nine and I ain't got no license.
Apparently all our shits rented.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm embarrassed to admit this,
but I would watch this over reading my
own articles.
So what the fuck I'm going to,
it will just give up.
Know what to do,
what to do.
What do we do?
Where's little Tay in 40 years?
That's what I want to know.
Where's the lighthouse?
Definitely the White House.
Where,
where else after Kanye is children.
When she's good,
she's going to be next.
I mean,
that's an interesting thought exercise
though.
Like where do you go down from Donald
Trump?
I mean,
cause the progression has to go down,
right?
Are we all done?
Cause I remember when Bush was
president,
uh,
like are we talking to reporters?
Bush used to do this thing where he
would carry around a biography of Dean
Aitchison,
um,
for weeks and weeks and weeks,
just approved reporters that he could
read.
Uh,
we all used to joke with each other
like,
nobody,
nobody's stupider than this is ever
going to be president.
And now you know,
you look back and,
and bushes,
you know,
he's,
he's like Einstein compared to,
to,
to trump.
I had a joke that I did back in my
netflix special from 2005 were when Bush
was in office where it was a bunch of
people were trying to figure out how
dumb people are.
And they're like,
the only way they like there
speculation.
Like,
let's get a smart guy to act dumb.
no,
no.
You got to get a real dumb guy.
Otherwise we'll never know.
You gotta have a real dumb guy.
And then so they get the real guy and
they put up do
a bunch of things,
you know,
they,
they vote him in a second time and then
someone in the back of the room goes,
I think we can go dumber
and this is where we are.
Right.
This is a bit from 2005 but you know,
13 years later,
life imitates art.
We went away.
Dumber.
That's right.
Right.
Well do a lab which seems super
reasonable in comparison to some of the
shit that trump says in terms of like
supreme court rulings and like,
um,
there was a supreme court ruling that
went against bushes way while he was an
office and he had a really reasonable
response.
He was like,
of course we're disappointed,
but we have to abide by the court and
their ruling.
And you know,
it was like something you would never
hear trump say.
Never hear him say something like that.
No,
absolutely.
I mean,
I,
I look back and Bush seems to me almost
like a Scandinavian statesmen compared
to compared to Donald Trump,
but
she would go to the White House to,
you know,
a lot of people did want to go to the
White House for the inauguration.
A little table go.
She'll go.
I mean,
the White House is good.
It's going to look like the White House
and idiocrasy when she's,
when she's in there.
Right.
I mean it's,
it's a,
it's,
it's going to be terrible,
but,
well,
that was a weird time too,
right?
Like during the inauguration when no
celebrities wanted to go and they dig
out like really weird,
like real fucking on the outskirts
celebrities.
It was,
yeah.
And it was the same thing with the RNC.
I cover,
I remember I covered the RNC and,
and uh,
and they had to have Scott Bayeux,
uh,
do one of the first day speeches.
Got bail is a huge supporter.
Right.
But I mean,
I know Scott,
I know personally,
it's very nice guy.
I'm sure he is.
I'm sure it has guy.
Yeah.
But that was their,
that was their,
a list for the Republican National
Convention and uh,
um,
outside of,
you know,
like the Hannitys and those type
fellows.
Right,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
Yeah,
it is.
It's just,
it's just weird.
It's,
it just seems like everything's off.
Like we,
we,
we skipped dimensions were like jolted
over isn't parallel world where things
just don't seem like at least things
used to make set.
Like you'd be disappointed at this guy
won or you'd be disappointed that the
country was doing this or that we were
invading Iraq or whatever it was.
But it would kind of seem like the
world.
Right.
Well,
this is it.
It's kind of like what we're talking
about.
We were talking about before,
I mean previously,
like the entertainment industry,
politics was tightly controlled by a
small group of Cigar chomping people who
sat in the back room and in both parties
they,
they had,
uh,
they carefully outlined a sort of
narrow,
a range of acceptable political
opinions.
And in one party,
you could be all the way up to,
you know,
somebody like Ron Paul,
but they tended to put somebody like
George Bush that as the candidate.
Um,
but you know,
there was no directly appealing to the
electorate and asking them who they want
it to be,
the candidate.
I mean,
Donald Trump is really the first
internet president.
He completely bypassed that entire
oligarchy.
He didn't have to go through,
um,
you know,
the priesthood to get to be president,
which on the one hand is evidence of a
good thing because it's actually more
democratic than the,
the,
the system was before where it was
pretty much close to everybody except
for a few people who paid their dues
through the system.
Uh,
but trump direct,
you know,
just by being famous and just by
attracting media attention,
uh,
he was able to bypass all of the usual
tests and bypass the parties,
you know,
decision making process,
and he got to be president.
But he's like little pay,
right?
I mean,
he's,
he just represents the dumber side of us
as opposed to the more enlightened side
of us.
So,
uh,
it's,
it's hard to know what to think about
it.
I mean,
I,
I when I was covering it,
I thought on the one hand,
this is evidence that the electorate is
breaking away from being told who to
vote for.
Uh,
on the other hand,
the first time they take it,
that freedom and for a test drive,
this is what they pick.
I mean,
I don't know lease,
it throws a giant monkey wrench into the
gears.
Right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's certainly done that.
But you know what,
what the result of that will be is,
is yet to be determined yet to be
determined.
Yeah.
I mean it could be the end of civil,
I said this before,
that,
you know,
when I was covering the trump run,
part of me wanted to write it as a
comedy.
Like all the early stories were like
highly comic.
I was trying to write about the funny
aspect of it and then after he became
president,
it's like,
well,
this is either the funniest thing that's
ever happened in America or it's the end
of civilization.
Right.
Does that make it funnier?
That's the end of the civilization.
I don't know.
I mean,
you're the erotic comics,
so I should,
I should ask you about,
I don't know either.
It's,
well,
it's,
it's all depending upon how it plays
out,
right?
I mean,
civilizations have absolutely fallen in
the past.
This idea that civilization won't fall,
in my opinion,
is akin to the people that live on the
big island thinking that the volcano
won't erupt again.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And it's going to happen again,
like so will,
our ideas about maintaining civilization
are an attempt to prolong this state or
mitigate any possible disastrous effects
of collapse.
Right.
But it's going to fall apart.
Of course,
it's an old system that was constructed
on scrolls by people writing with
feathered.
They really had no idea what the future
hadn't stall.
Right.
We didn't,
they didn't know what the future had in
store.
They had no,
they would have
been terrified by a toothbrush.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
Well,
certainly by a fucking airplane and
cellular communication and this,
we live in a world that requires a
completely new set of rules and
guidelines.
And you know,
this has always been the article against
the second amendment like,
okay,
did they had muskets when they wrote
this?
They didn't have ar fifteens.
They didn't have 50 caliber guns that
can kill things.
One,
they miss them playing a video yesterday
of a guy shooting a deer and with a 50
caliber rifle and he misses the deer and
it still kills the deer.
The bullet going past the deer's head,
just of sheer force of it blows the
deer's brains out dead.
Is that actually it happened?
Oh yeah,
I want to watch it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Pull it up.
Keep that one on a favorites to make a
folder for shit.
We repetitively talk about
when I was embedded,
interact,
they,
they took me out and the guys apparently
for recreation and they,
they cut cars and half with 50 cal
calibers.
Here's the,
here's the gun.
Now watch this.
He misses boom and watch it.
It just falls down dead
from the bullet passing it.
This is like Jesus.
It just whizzed by it and the force of
the bullet passing by.
He's psyched,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Watch.
But watch the slow Mo,
it just falls down.
He's like,
thank God this guy's got Cammo on a
million miles away and literally sitting
on a bench,
he's on a bench shooting something in
the distance,
but he picks his deer up and the deer's
brains,
we just completely scrambled.
No,
no bolt wound at all.
Nothing.
No whole dead.
That's a,
that's a horror movie waiting to happen.
That deer's going to wake up in the
middle of the night and,
and reanimated and uh Oh,
what happened?
So the brands coming out of the ears
coming out of the ears.
Yeah,
just from the sheer force of the bullet
passing it.
Jesus.
That's all I'm saying is it would be a
good time to reconsider how we run
things.
And I think one of the good things about
having a guy like trump and offices,
maybe we should sit down and say,
hey,
we probably shouldn't have a popularity
contest.
So he who controls the nukes?
See who's the commander in chief of the
greatest army that the planet has ever
known right?
Far the most destructive force the
planet has ever known.
Shouldn't we?
At least find out if he's on diet pills,
right.
Shouldn't be at least shouldn't be
saved.
Mr President,
we'd like a urine sample from you.
Yeah,
exactly.
After They Test Your pee if you work at
ups.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I think there,
there should be more a pee test
for launching a nuclear strike.
Definitely
spit a lot.
Lot of changes and one thing I'm hoping
is that this does this presidency and
the,
the whole idea of like having a
popularity contest will allow people to
realize like,
first of all,
we shouldn't have one alpha champ
running things.
That's,
that's an antiquated idea.
That was really great.
And a tribe of 50 nomads,
right.
Get them together and you have the
wisest,
strongest one with the most battle
experience.
That guy should be running things.
He knows more than I do.
Right?
I get it.
Let's vote for ORC or,
or it's the guy with the knowledge,
you know,
it makes sense,
but when there's 350 million people and
you have the ability to manipulate
things and you have tweets and facebook
posts and write could make wacky little
tay videos were not designed for this.
No,
no.
And
we have some structures that rely on the
popularity contest and some that have,
the public has no control over
whatsoever.
Like Federal Reserve.
Like it doesn't,
a lot of it makes no sense at all.
Or how net neutrality got passed with
five different people or how it got
rescinded.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
exactly.
yeah.
No,
I mean it's,
the system doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense.
The,
the,
the s Congress and uncovering
congressional races now in the run up to
two,
2018 and you know,
the process is almost 100% about money.
It's just like,
you know,
like I talked to a guy who was,
who,
who jumped in and in the ring to run for
a seat in the,
in the 19th district.
And he told me he calls up the National
Party and they re they basically had
two,
two questions for him.
Like can you raise $300,000 within the
next three months and can you raise $1
million by election day?
And you know,
that was the whole of the conversation
and,
and it has to be based on more than
something,
more than how much money can you raise
a,
we have to do that.
There has to be another variable for
picking leaders,
uh,
beyond,
you know,
how much cash can you get your hands on
in the next few months?
Do you see that Rosie O'donnell got in
trouble for,
uh,
raising money under various names and,
and donating too much money.
It's like Roy,
Roy Moore's a opponents and wow.
Yeah.
What,
what exactly happened?
I read that she had used a website that
she thought should have stopped her from
donating the extra amount cause it was
being divvied amongst many people and
that it should have been returned to
her,
which I s I don't know enough about it
that,
uh,
candidates are supposed to return extra
funds once they've crossed over the
amount that a individual is supposed to
give.
And it didn't happen in this,
these cases,
and it should have happened.
And I don't know.
It doesn't,
she know how much you're supposed to
donate isn't there's free.
That's what she was saying.
She's $2,700.
Right.
She used a website and she just gave him
a shit load of money,
I think.
Oh,
I see.
But I thought she used different names.
I don't know about that part.
I didn't hear about that part.
We should probably that up.
Yeah,
there were,
that
was one of the,
um,
sort of stories that wasn't followed up
after 2016,
but it was,
it was one of the things that came out
in the,
in those hacked dnc,
um,
uh,
things was that there was,
a little bit of a scam going on in terms
of,
um,
you know,
the,
as you see it,
the individual donor living donation
limit is pretty small.
It's like $2,700 for an individual.
So a couple,
it's $5,400.
So what they would do is they would host
these,
these dinners with celebrities,
like,
you know,
George Clooney and a bunch of his
friends.
And,
uh,
they would raise all this money and
theoretically the money was supposed to
go only a tiny portion of it to the
presidential campaign and the rest of
it's supposed to go to the regional
parties.
But what was actually happening
according to politico anyway,
a,
was that the money was basically going
to the parties and then going
immediately back to the presidential
campaign.
And,
and,
uh,
they,
a lot of the people who gave the money
didn't even know that that was happening
and
they were upset about it.
And,
uh,
and,
but that was a story that wasn't
followed up after,
after 2016.
Yeah.
There's just entirely too much money.
Totally.
Too much money in politics.
But how would you ever do it without the
money?
Now,
once the money's in,
how do you pull it out?
How do you say no,
no,
no more influence.
No more special interest groups.
Lobbyists are illegal.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I think they should,
they should probably have very brief,
publicly funded elections where
there's a,
you know,
the,
the course of time is maybe five weeks.
And what,
Oh,
is this assists the O'donnell thing?
Yeah.
It says,
Hell Donald Doty donated $4,700 to a
bomb.
Uh,
Alabama Senator Doug Jones.
And His special action against Roy
Moore,
$3,600 to Pennsylvania Rep conard lamb
for the special general electric.
He won in March,
2000 952 California Rep Adam Schiff for
his primary $4,200 to Illinois
congressional candidate,
Lauren Underwood for her primary run in
3,404 52 oh Omar Vade,
a congressional candidate in Staten
Island and Brooklyn.
Nothing nefarious.
She's Rosie O'donnell says I was not
choosing to over donate the $2,700
cutoff,
uh,
candidates she'd prefer refund the
money.
She wrote a,
I don't look to see who I can donate
most too.
I just donate assuming they do not
accept what is over the limit.
Hmm.
Right.
Yeah.
I Dunno how
I am by that explanation,
but uh,
it doesn't really matter because the
reality is
there are million ways that you can
legally give money to campaigns now that
don't involve just the individual
donation.
Like you can,
you know,
you can give money to a foundation or a,
a five o one c three or whatever it is
that buys an ad,
uh,
that will help the candidate just as
much as the you as,
as it would
if you don't do I need to directly.
So,
you know,
in the post citizens United Universe,
this is this,
this is a,
it's a story,
but you know,
the bigger story is that you can base
the very rich people and companies can
basically spend unlimited amounts of
money on,
on campaigns.
And yeah,
this is,
this whole story is over.
Like what was that all told for $5,000
most?
Yeah.
Not a lot.
No,
I don't,
that doesn't,
I mean,
you know,
I don't have feelings one way or another
about Rosie O'donnell,
but not,
I,
that doesn't make me outraged terribly.
Well,
trump hates her.
Right.
What's fascinating about it at all?
Yeah.
Well he,
he,
he got a big bump from talking about her
in the debate and you know,
that,
that was another thing that he did very
early on as he clued into the fact that
people hate people hate journalists and
they,
Hollywood actors.
And so he made,
he made sure as much as possible to talk
about,
uh,
all the,
all the groups,
the major food groups of,
of,
of hate in America,
right?
Like immigrants,
Hillary Clinton,
Hollywood actors and reporters.
And those were the staples of his
routine.
And,
and,
uh,
it worked.
I mean,
it was,
it was smart on his part.
Uh,
I think particularly the targeting of
journalists was brilliant because he was
able to portray us as the wealthy elite.
And,
you know,
he's the billionaire.
Uh,
but he's pointing the finger at us as
I'll look to,
you know,
they're the guardians of,
of rich America,
which,
which worked and what wasn't brilliant
thing.
It's just,
um,
it's unprecedented.
Yeah.
What was the last time any presidential
among maybe Nixon complained about them
at the time,
but I believe it was privately.
Yeah.
Well he,
he,
he hated the press pretty openly.
I mean,
he had that 1962 press conference where
he's like,
you won't have Nixon to kick around
anymore.
Uh,
and,
uh,
he from all accounts,
he was an incredibly profane,
nasty person in private,
and he only talked to a few reporters.
Um,
I mean,
I think all politicians hate reporters
if they,
if they don't,
uh,
there's probably something wrong with
them because,
you know,
the press corps in most cases is,
is really is out to get them,
um,
or at least as dangerous,
you know.
Uh,
but with trump and Nixon,
it was,
it went to a whole new level and,
and went to a paranoid place and,
um,
you know,
but on the other hand,
I don't mean to bore you with this,
but,
but the,
the whining about being kicked out of
the White House and not being able to
fly with,
with trump and,
and the sort of separation between the
president and the press corps and the
fact he doesn't show up at the White
House correspondence dinner,
like as a reporter,
I,
my response to that is,
so what we should be on the outside.
You know,
like,
I,
I don't,
I don't shed a tear about that.
I think it's very strange the response
in our business that,
uh,
oh,
you know,
we're,
we're not,
we don't get to be hanging around with
the president and,
and,
uh,
you know,
pal around behind the rope line with
them anymore.
Like we,
we should be adversarial I think.
Yeah.
Well if as long as you're honest and
accurate.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
did you,
not even adversarial,
but not connected,
right,
right.
It's,
it's,
it's a kind of a separation of church
and state thing for me.
Like I had an experience when I,
when I covered the Obama campaign and I
like Barack Obama as a candidate in
2008.
I was really impressed by him.
But I remember going into the plane the
first time going back into the press
section and I see that there's photos
all over the walls of the,
of the campaign plane.
And apparently there's a tradition where
each of the reporters had like a little
sort of high school yearbook photo taken
with the candidate where,
you know,
they got their arm around a Obama and
they're posing.
And it was a tradition to kind of put
the photo up on the wall.
Uh,
and I'm like,
you know,
this is not a good look for the press
corps.
Even if you like the guy,
you got to at least pretend to have a
little bit of that.
The mode is supposed to be there.
You know what I mean?
What's,
this is certainly influential.
Yes.
Certainly going to have some sort of an
influence on you.
Yeah.
It's just a bad look.
Like what happens if you do a story
about the guy that's complimentary and
it comes out that,
you know,
you're,
you've put a picture of yourself with
your arm around the guy.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
that's,
reporters are kind of supposed to be
these unpleasant,
uh,
you know,
kind of grumpy people who instantly
deface the posters of,
you know,
powerful people.
Uh,
you know,
when,
whenever they get a chance and throw
darts at pictures of them and stuff like
that,
like that,
that's who they kind of used to be.
And you see there's people that are
jockeying for position to potentially
run in.
You know,
the next election,
obviously the 2018 elections,
but in 2020 for president,
he seen people that are moving into
position.
You see these congressional candidates
that are showing promise.
Like what,
what is the,
when you're covering this,
so like,
what's the,
what's the feeling of like the future
from these races?
So like,
what is it from the standpoint of
reporters like when like,
yeah,
well first,
first of all,
like the,
the holy grail of reporting is to latch
onto a politician before they become
famous and before they become president
and follow them all the way.
And that way you get to be the insider
who gets invited into the Oval Office.
So it's,
it's like,
uh,
it's a big thing that a lot of reporters
kind of dream of his to his,
to latch on early to somebody like Bill
Clinton,
uh,
and become the,
the sort of favored reporter on that
beat.
Um,
that's why at the outset of presidential
elections,
you'll often see a lot of jockeying
within newsrooms to see who gets to
cover which campaign.
Because,
um,
people always want to pick the winner
because they think they're going to get
a book deal out of it at the end and
you're going to end up having their own
show on MSNBC or whatever.
But the,
um,
but yeah,
I mean the w w what's the feeling right
now?
Like who are people coalescing around?
Um,
is that what you're asking that too?
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
I think there's,
the expectation is that some of the same
people are going to be involved.
I think there's,
there's a lot of belief that Bernie's
going to run again.
But then there's also a Kamala Harris,
there's,
uh,
cory booker.
Um,
you know,
people believe that those,
those,
those folks are gonna run.
Um,
but,
uh,
it,
oddly enough,
the press corps is less focused on that
than they would be normally.
Uh,
I think they're the only story that
matters to political reporters right now
as the Russia gate trump thing.
And they're following that and kind of
hoping that will be some,
the thing that happens instead of the
20,
20 election,
you know,
that they're there.
The big,
the big sort of trial of Donald Trump is
what everybody's kind of waiting for.
Well,
the recent take on that is that there is
some sort of a connection between
Russian oligarchs and Michael Cohen.
Right.
There's something that he moved the Vec
Vekselberg uh,
payment.
I just heard about that this morning.
So I can't say that I know a whole lot
about that.
Um,
what would that payment before?
When was it?
You know,
it was allegedly after the elections,
so that would be a story.
I mean,
I,
I've gotten a lot of criticism because I
had been a little bit of a skeptic on
the Russia Gate Front.
Um,
not so much that I don't believe it,
but I just kind of think the press
should be a little careful about it.
Uh,
but if that's true,
yeah.
She,
that's a big story.
If,
if Cohen really was in Prague,
that's also a really big story.
Um,
you know,
but we'll have to see what those,
what,
what really comes out of that.
It's just such an unusual moment in
history.
Oh yeah.
It's crazy.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's the,
as unstable as American history's been
in our lifetime,
certainly.
Right.
I would think,
you know,
he ever,
yeah.
Or close to it.
Right?
The civil war on,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you add in the fact that we've had
concerns about nuclear conflict with two
different nations,
right.
And since,
since trump has been elected,
I mean there's,
there's the North Korea thing and then
there's the fact that we've had military
exchanges where Russian mercenaries,
uh,
you know,
reportedly have died.
Um,
you know,
they,
that's certainly unnerving.
You know,
the,
the nuclear clock,
which was established,
the doomsday clock,
which was established way back in the
fifties,
um,
has us at the,
the most dangerous points since 1953.
I'm merely,
yeah,
yeah.
And,
uh,
at a,
at a time in their estimation,
I forget what the,
the,
the organization is actually called,
but,
um,
uh,
I think it's physicians for social
responsibility.
Uh,
but the,
you know,
the,
this right now is more dangerous than,
you know,
the,
the k seven shooting the Cuban missile
crisis.
Like,
we're,
we're at a a moment that's incredibly
tense between these two countries and
more so than the Cuban missile crisis in
their estimation.
Yeah.
Who's estimating this there?
It's called the doomsday clock.
You can find it as a metric.
Just the,
the,
you know,
I guess they're just reading the news
like everybody else,
but,
um,
you know,
they,
uh,
I don't know it,
it's off derided by,
uh,
by people in Washington has been
Washington as being too hysterical.
Um,
but you know,
it,
it is an indicator.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the people who,
um,
who do it,
uh,
I think are the same people who want to
win Nobel prize last year for,
um,
the sort of anti nuclear,
uh,
the,
the UN ban,
uh,
on,
on nuclear weapons.
So [inaudible] nine 11,
we used to have a terrorist threat
colors.
Yeah.
Robert Mueller was on the board,
uh,
the,
every day they used to have a meeting of
a group of people in the various
intelligence agencies to decide what the
color would be,
um,
as a yellow.
Yeah,
exactly.
And what,
what's fascinating about this tonight,
I only heard about this cause I wrote
about this a few months ago and I made a
mistake by saying that it,
the,
uh,
the color used to toggle between red,
which was the highest and green,
which was the lowest,
but apparently not once in its entire
history.
Was it ever green?
Like the,
the,
they never had threat level low,
even won a once in its history.
So we were,
oh,
we were always at some level of anxiety.
But those,
those are weird times to remember that
when they used to kind of tell us how
scared we were supposed to be about
about stuff.
And with a real simple distinction like
colors,
right?
Yeah.
Today's orange.
Holy Shit.
It's orange dude.
Be careful.
You're going to fly today.
That's more,
yeah.
Are you going to go to an airport today?
It's orange.
I'm not going to the superbowl.
Today's orange.
Yeah.
Crazy stuff to read.
Oh yeah,
I think so.
It had to have a,
and then they just stopped.
Right?
Well,
so the,
the,
the program,
uh,
it took a huge hit when,
um,
one of the guys who was involved who was
the former head of homeland security,
if I'm not mistaken,
came out with a story that he had been
told by some of the Bush people to Jack
up the,
uh,
the color in advance of an election.
Uh,
and,
um,
it was shortly after that story came out
that they discontinued the program.
Uh,
it came out in the book by,
by the former head of the homeland
security,
right before an election.
There were told time to go orange.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Because they wanted to build up.
Right.
I mean,
it was this,
you get people scared and they'll vote,
vote a certain way.
And Yeah.
So,
yeah.
Amazing Times though.
Yeah.
As a journalist,
do you look at these times and say,
this is great,
this is great for business,
or do you,
do you more so look at it as a human
being and go,
this is just a fucking mess.
And I wish we weren't so ridiculous.
So when,
when I first started covering the trump
campaign,
I thought this is the most awesome thing
ever because,
uh,
eh,
that dynamic I was talking about before
about,
about reporters wanting to be on the
ground floor with,
with the future winner.
Um,
nobody wanted to be on the trump
campaign because nobody thought he was
going to win.
I was stoked to the assigned to cover
trump because I thought this is the most
insane thing ever.
And He,
you know,
maybe you can fit your style of
journalism.
Yeah,
exactly.
I thought this is,
this is the black comedy that I was then
I was sort of born to cover and born,
born to write.
And for the first,
I dunno,
five or six things that I wrote about
it,
I,
um,
about trump,
I thought it was the most amazing,
crazy,
interesting story of my lifetime.
And then it took this incredibly dark
term where he actually won.
And,
um,
I think it was a dark term for him too.
Yeah.
There's no question about it.
There's no,
I mean I knew some of the people in his
campaign,
I can't say this definitively,
but I,
I have a very good educated guests that
they had absolutely no expectation of it
ever even been close,
let alone winning and that and that
they,
uh,
that they did this as a publicity stunt
in the beginning,
probably with the aim of either creating
a media network or just bolstering
trump's overall q rating or whatever it
was.
NBC might've pushed him towards the
presidency by firing him from the
apprentice.
Uh,
yeah,
cause he was still the host of that
fucking show while he was running for
president.
They fire him and then arnold takes
over.
People forgot already and Arnold
Schwartzenegger with for a very short
time.
You're fired.
He was the guy for a while.
Yeah.
They had that flame war,
remember?
Yeah.
It was really weird.
Fucking strange.
But NBC might have given him the final,
you know,
you might have taken an extra diet pill
that day and went,
fuck it.
We're going all in the wall.
Got 10 feet higher
on Swartz.
Bigger says he's done with apprentice
blames
poor ratings on trump involvement.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's right.
Yeah.
They had that whole back and forth over
who was to blame for the ratings.
But uh,
listen,
as a host of that show,
Donald Trump was crate.
Oh yeah,
he's the perfect guys.
The whole statue.
Arnold's too nice.
It's not the right guy.
He's not a billionaire asshole.
Yeah,
no,
you need a total jackass and,
and get it done.
One of those guys,
you need one of those guys.
You got fired.
And the,
the,
the same thing that made trump perfect
for that show made him perfect as the
main protagonist in campaign coverage,
which is actually really just a really
long super boring reality show,
or at least it used to be until trump
came along.
Uh,
trump completely changed the dynamic of
it.
You know,
if you're,
if you're thinking of it in terms of how
it looks to a network,
what were the networks thinking before?
If they,
if they were going to have people like
Scott Walker and Lindsey Graham be the
stars of,
of their lead reality show.
Like,
let's get a real performer in there.
Right?
And,
and when they did,
when they,
when,
when trump entered the fray and became a
real candidate and started getting
votes,
suddenly news started making money and
like for like real money for the first
time.
And there a,
there's an amazing data point right now,
which is that the public trusts the
press less than ever,
right?
They believe the things that we say less
than ever,
all the polls show this,
that there's been a dramatic downturn
and how much people will put stock in
and things that people like me say,
right?
Uh,
but they're watching television,
television news more than they ever have
by a lot.
So what are those two data points say
together,
put together that people are consuming
news not as news,
but it's entertainment there.
There,
there are watching it more,
right?
So we're,
we've,
you know,
CNN made over $1 billion last year.
They're just eating into the
entertainment budget.
That's,
that's all they're doing.
And it's all trump.
Uh,
which is,
is fascinating and kind of horrifying,
but,
but really interesting too.
Isn't that also what he played upon when
he was running,
like he would say outrageous shit.
So they would cover him.
And that essentially gave him free
press.
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And He,
there was no doubt in my mind that,
that he was doing that intentionally.
I remember watching him and I'm in New
Hampshire where he's giving a speech and
you probably remember this,
this woman stood up and said,
ted Cruz,
the pussy.
All right.
And,
uh,
and trump looks over at her and he says,
oh,
that's terrible.
That's terrible.
She just had a terrible thing about Ted
Cruz.
Right.
And I remember,
I remember him looking over at the,
at the rise of where all the cameras
are,
and you could see him thinking,
he's thinking it's a story for six
hours.
If she says it,
it's a story for three days.
That's why I say it.
Right.
And he,
he thinks,
and he goes,
he just said that Ted Cruz is a pussy a
right.
And next thing you know,
it like completely dominated the news.
And,
and he,
he comes,
he understood the dynamic of how the
news works better than,
than even the people in the news
understood it.
Well,
certainly better than Ted Cruz,
that's for sure.
Ted Cruz,
that the recent praise of trump,
and then they go back to like what he
said during the campaign.
Oh my God.
It's no one should ever listen to him
ever again about anything.
Oh yeah,
no,
it was a,
it was,
it's hilarious.
Ted Cruz,
you know,
first of all,
my favorite part of that whole campaign
was the thing that he couldn't shake
about being the Zodiac killer.
Like,
uh,
and,
and reporters would give him shit about
it.
Like,
like we would talk amongst each other,
like,
who's going to ask him about it the
next,
you know,
and,
um,
and everybody knew that it was,
it was bullshit.
You know,
that he was born after the killing
started and everything,
all that stuff.
But somebody would always make it a
point to say,
so what do you think about the,
you know,
the rumors about,
and you could see that it just,
it completely drove him to distraction.
He didn't know how to,
how to make a joke out of it or,
yeah.
Well,
I know you're a hunter s thompson fancy.
You were probably aware of what a hunter
did to Ed Muskie.
Oh yeah.
The IBOGAINE.
Yeah,
absolutely.
He went crazy.
Literally went crazy.
A hunter.
It was,
what was it on the Dick Cavett show that
he talked about it?
Well,
there was a rumor he had,
uh,
taken Ibogaine and,
I knew about that rumor because I
started it.
He drove that guy crazy to the point
where you see,
I think it was in New Hampshire,
he was giving a political campaign
speech and he broke down.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He cried.
Yeah.
Well he,
so hundreds of this great thing.
He,
he,
he wrote about it.
It was,
it was kind of a spoof of campaign
coverage because he,
he,
he did this whole,
uh,
campaign diary and then he just kind of
went into this dead Pan,
a recitation of what sounded like a
breaking news story about him
discovering,
uh,
muskies secret relationship with a witch
doctor who was providing him with it
will gain.
And then,
then,
then he,
he dug up some file photo of Musky that
look like this.
It was like,
and he,
they put,
you know,
must ed Musky in the grips of an Igbo
gain.
Frenzy was the caption and a,
it was completely dead pan.
He never said he was kidding.
I've never seen that.
Never said it was,
you know,
not like that was fiction and uh,
and Musky couldn't handle it.
I mean,
that was probably the first real
political trolling that went on.
But,
uh,
and a brilliant one too,
because I began,
it's not even in that kind of a drug.
It's a drug that helps people get off
drugs,
oddly enough.
Illegal,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
In America,
in America.
It's legal in a lot of places,
but it's really great for people getting
off opiates.
Huh.
It's it just a ferociously introspective
drug that rewires the way your brain
deals with addictions.
It literally rewires the connections,
alleviates addictions on a physical and
psychological level.
What's the,
what does it feel like?
I don't know.
I haven't done,
I haven't done it on that one.
Yeah.
I know quite a few people that have,
that have had pill problems,
have gone to Mexico and taking my friend
Ed Clay,
who has an actual center down there now,
he started it,
uh,
after he had gone down there for
treatment,
he had a back injury,
I believe it was,
and got hooked on pills and I was like,
Jesus,
I got to figure out a way to get off
these fucking things and did Ibogaine
and then cleared it right up.
Wow.
You realize like,
wow,
like this is,
this is crazy,
that this is illegal.
So the one drug that hunter chose was
actually a drug that gets people off
drugs.
It just even more ironic.
It just had a great name.
Yeah.
And doctor,
Bro.
It's fucking awesome.
So that,
that really was the original political
troll.
Yeah.
And it might have had a giant effect in
the election.
Probably did.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
and I don't think it was an accident
that
hunter's coverage was,
you know,
that,
that he,
he chose that year to do these diaries.
And I remember my father telling me
about however report or would,
would wait for rolling stone to come out
that week so they could,
you know,
read the coverage of the election.
But,
you know,
hunter kind of,
uh,
took this unknown unknown senator,
from the Dakotas,
George Mcgovern and made them into this,
uh,
because this like Christ figure
basically.
And I don't,
I don't think that mcgovern would have
won the nomination without,
without that sort of relentless hyping
that he gave him because it probably
would have won the presidency if it
wasn't for the vice president having
that issue with,
he had gone through electroshock
therapy.
Eagleton right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was a,
that was terrible.
But,
uh,
but fascinating.
You know,
I,
I got to write the introduction to the,
to the last,
um,
last version of that book.
And,
um,
that's one of my favorite books of all
time.
Great fucking book.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's just like a,
it's such a crazy economic ethic,
you know,
he was a big influence of yours.
Uh,
yeah.
You know,
I,
um,
definitely I think the,
the great thing of a Hunter Thompson,
um,
first of all,
he just,
he was so incredibly funny in a way that
was completely rare.
I mean,
you,
you can't just trained to be that way.
You either are born with that ability,
uh,
verbally or not.
And he just had this completely strange
four dimensional way of looking at
things.
And,
uh,
you know,
he would,
he would a completely boring a campaign
speech.
And when he got done writing it up,
it was like,
you know,
uh,
a psychedelic wrestling match or
something like that.
I mean,
it was,
it was so much more interesting and
bizarre and weird,
and he saw these great details and,
um,
and he was just,
I,
I think it was a great approach to
journalism,
but,
you know,
sadly there aren't that many people who
can pull it off because it just
required,
um,
you know,
surpassing literary talent.
And that's,
that's,
that's incredibly rare.
What was a unique combination of fiction
writing along with like
an actual understanding analysis?
Yeah.
That was,
that was his,
his cause is great cause it,
cause you're right,
he,
he would bring you in and,
uh,
the,
the reader would,
would kind of surf along this
incredibly,
uh,
charged,
fast paced,
uh,
a narrative that read like,
you know,
the,
the fastest,
most engrossing fiction or,
uh,
but he would intersperse it and stop and
pull back a and do a,
what we call it,
a rolling stone.
We call them wisdoms,
right?
Where,
you know,
he's just sort of stop and say,
here,
here's my take on this.
And those were amazing.
I mean,
he just,
he just had this ability to sort of cut
through the bullshit and see,
see things from an angle that nobody
else saw.
And that was the,
uh,
rare technique back then.
The,
I,
the idea of the kind of individualized,
um,
take on things.
Uh,
nobody was doing that and reporting back
then.
I mean it was the,
no,
nobody even thought of it as a form,
as a form that you can really experiment
with.
I mean,
there were a few people back then like
terry southern and Tom Wolfe who were,
who were doing some things like that,
but,
but Thompson was completely unique.
Uh,
and there hasn't been anybody like him,
you know.
So since,
since then I think,
I think,
uh,
um,
it's,
it's not an accident that nobody's been
able to pull that off again now.
Well,
you get compared to him a lot.
And,
um,
one one way I really saw that comparison
was your brilliant coverage of the
financial crisis and what was the,
the mechanisms behind the scene of the
financial crisis and that I became a
really big fan of your work,
uh,
reading that because that I think you
covered that as well,
if not better than anybody.
Oh,
thanks.
Yeah.
I mean,
so I,
I knew nothing about any,
I couldn't even balance my checkbook
when they assigned me to that story.
And,
um,
and I had to start basically from square
one and,
uh,
I was calling people and saying things
like,
can you tell me something about
something that I'll understand?
You know,
I was kind of cold calling investment
banks and literally saying that.
And I finally got a guy to,
to have lunch with me and he said,
your problem is that you're trying to
understand this as an economic story.
Um,
once you look at it as a crime story,
you'll get it.
Uh,
and,
and from that point forward,
I,
I totally,
I felt like I,
I started to understand the whole
mechanism wa the sub prime mortgage
scam.
It really was a scam.
It's really,
it's really just a massive corporatized
version of like selling a Oregano is,
we'd basically,
uh,
they,
they took stuff that these,
these incredibly worthless,
a highly risky mortgage loans,
right?
You know,
they would give out loans to everybody
with a pulse.
Um,
you know,
whether you had a job or not,
whether you were a citizen or not,
didn't matter.
Port thing was to get the loan
immediately,
sell it off,
chop it up,
turn it into securities,
and then they use this highly advanced,
um,
sort of mathematical trick to turn all
that sort of mortgage hamburger into
triple a rated securities.
So you'd have like a,
you know,
a junk rated mortgage,
like the riskiest a loan in existence.
Uh,
something that was so toxic that country
companies like country ride wouldn't
want to hold onto it for more than a
week because they were afraid it would,
the stuff would blow up and then they
would sell it off to like a pension fund
or,
um,
you know,
an insurance company in the form of a
AAA rated security,
which,
you know,
is as safe as a US treasury bond.
So it was,
it was a scam.
Uh,
again,
the,
the metaphor of,
you know,
baby powder taking baby powder and
selling it as coke or whatever,
that that's exactly what it was.
They just took worthless shit and sold
it as something that was,
that was gold.
Uh,
and they got,
they did it for years and years and
years and years,
and they,
they knew that this gigantic,
huge bubble of risk and disaster was
just accumulating and that someday it
was going to all explode and cascade
and,
and ruined the economy.
But everybody was trying to time it,
right.
And,
and bet on when that would happen and
make their money before that,
that Judgment Day came.
And,
uh,
it was,
it was fascinating once I,
once I started to learn about it,
it was just such an amazingly
disgusting,
a fascinating story that,
um,
it was just hard not to,
not to get into it a crime story.
Yeah.
I think of it as a crime story.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I even got,
one guy gave me a book,
um,
it was called famous famous con artists
in history,
right?
It was like this little tome,
uh,
and smaller than like the smallest paper
back.
And it was the biography of this guy,
Victor Lustig was his name.
He was famous because he sold the Eiffel
Tower twice.
All right.
Uh,
and um,
he,
he had this,
uh,
this scam that he called,
I think it was called the,
the,
the Hungarian box.
Um,
I'll have to go back and look,
but basically what he would do is he
would get on a boat,
um,
in New York and he had this,
uh,
sort of beautiful Mahogany box with a
crank on it that had two holes in it.
And he would show all the guests that he
would put a blank piece of paper and one
and turn a crank and a hundred dollar
bill would come out the other end.
Uh,
and he convinced them all that it was a
machine that made money and,
uh,
everybody would offer him an increasing
amount of money for this invention.
Uh,
and he wouldn't sell it until the last
day,
uh,
when he would sell it for,
you know,
40 or $50,000,
and then he would disappear and jump off
the boat and in France and never be seen
again.
People would,
yeah,
there it is.
What's it called?
Uh,
wow.
Yeah,
there it is.
Um,
but um,
but that's exactly what the mortgage,
let me see his face.
Look at that fucking creep lugging them.
Wow.
Let me see that box again.
That is crazy.
So the,
yeah,
so it was obviously fake and,
and,
but that's what the Morgan scam was.
They,
they,
they were taking basically blank paper,
these,
these sub prime loans that belonged to
janitors who were going to foreclose
within 10 minutes.
All right.
And they were telling people that,
oh,
we have this new mathematical process
that allows,
that actually makes this stuff really
safe.
Um,
and you can put it in your,
uh,
in your college endowment,
you can put in your pension fund.
And so all these people,
you know,
who his retirement monies were based on,
on security is we're buying all this
shit that they thought was,
was aaa aerated.
And that's,
that's how they woke up and you know,
and in 2008,
2009 and they found their 401ks where
we're,
you know,
wiped out by 40% or whatever it was.
My neighbor really did that happen to
him.
My neighbor bought this plot of land
and,
uh,
had this dream to build his dream house.
And,
uh,
he would go buy the plot of land and
there was always cleaned it up and
getting ready and I was talking to him
and then,
boom,
2008 happened.
He lost everything.
And he would still go by that plot of
land and cleaning it up.
And he and I would talk about it and
they just told me he lost everything.
Yeah.
So Never gonna Happen,
Huh?
Yeah.
No,
I think he,
uh,
I think he died.
He eventually got really sick and they
took him out of his house and brought
them somewhere,
but I think he's dead now.
But yeah,
his,
uh,
his story was awful,
awful to hear this guy who was in his
sixties who had got this piece of land
with a nice view and it's like,
this is where I'm going to drink,
build my dream house.
And he had all this money prepared for
it,
all this money saved away and he was
ready to rock and roll and then boom,
it all went out.
It just drained out.
Somebody put a hole in the bottom of the
boat and everything,
everything went to the bottom of the
ocean.
Yeah.
And then he'd probably got ripped off
twice because it's tax dollars went to
go bail out the guys who,
uh,
you know,
cause some of the,
some of the banks got stuck holding some
of this shit.
And rather than eat the loss is like
your,
your friend did.
They got the Federal Reserve to buy it
from them,
you know?
And,
and,
or,
or the treasury.
So all the fuck did they get away with
giving the Ceos bonuses during that
time?
Yeah,
I mean,
I ain't bonuses during the time where
the,
they had to be bailed out by the
taxpayers.
Yeah.
That was another scam.
Like,
so there were,
if you looked at the fine print of all
the bail outs,
it's basically said that,
um,
you had to repay the money by us by x
time before you could start paying
people exorbitant amounts of money
again.
Uh,
but a lot of those,
a lot of those conditions were never
really followed.
And you know,
the,
the conditions of repayment we're kind
of glossed over.
And,
um,
the,
the companies that they were supposed to
be able to pass these things called
stress tests,
which demonstrated that they were back
on solid footing again before they paid
people a bonuses.
But the stress tests are all fudged in,
you know,
I mean,
there were,
there was crime and corruption
illegality basically in every direction
during that whole period.
And,
and,
uh,
not just in the government,
but in,
in all of these companies as well.
Jesus.
Yeah.
But fascinating to,
to,
to follow.
Yeah.
What was it like covering that?
I mean,
how long,
how long did you spend working on that?
Seven years probably riced yeah.
Well,
cause one of the things that I found,
nothing it was really interesting was
I did my first story about this and I
got this incredible reaction because it
turns out that the financial press,
there is nobody in the financial press
who writes for ordinary people.
Like it's basically what I was doing was
a translation job.
I was trying to basically take what had
happened and explain it in a way that a
person who knew nothing about finance
would be able to understand.
Uh,
and it turns out that nobody's doing
that.
So all these people who had questions
about who,
who wanted to know what had happened to
their money or why,
why did my house get foreclosed on or
what,
you know,
what's,
what's a subprime mortgage or anything.
Um,
you know,
there,
there was nobody else doing that work.
So I had lots of it to do.
And it was,
it was really interesting and I just
kept doing it.
Wow.
That had to be depressing.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
of course.
Of course.
I mean,
most,
most investigative reporting is
depressing.
Uh,
look particularly that because I mean,
a lot of it was old people that when got
old people,
minorities.
I mean,
uh,
I did one story about,
um,
a bank,
uh,
in Maryland.
Well,
it's a national bank.
It's a bank that,
you know,
I wouldn't be surprised that a lot of
people listening how have their accounts
with this bank,
um,
they,
uh,
had to pay a settlement to the
government because they were,
uh,
intentionally targeting elderly black
people,
uh,
to sell sub prime mortgages to,
and they called the mud people.
Uh,
and there were all these,
these plague toxic emails going back and
forth about how stupid they were and how
they'll buy anything,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Emails,
they call them mud people.
Yeah.
And so they had to pay a settlement to
the government and,
but the,
you know,
the racial component of the,
of,
of that crash was something that I
didn't really clue into it until late,
but that was a big part of it too.
It was,
um,
a lot of it involved these mortgage
lenders going into particularly like
lower middle class black neighborhoods
and knocking on doors where there'd be
like an elderly person at home and
saying,
hey,
would you like to refi your mortgage and
you'll have a little bit of extra
spending money this month.
Right.
And the person won't know anything about
finance and they'll,
they'll sign this refinance deal that
allows them to save a little bit of
money each month.
Not knowing that they had just converted
their fixed mortgage into a floating
mortgage.
And that is seen as the interest rates
changed.
You know,
you'd have people who went from paying
$900 a month to paying $7,000 a month,
right.
And suddenly they're out in the street
and,
and you know,
the,
uh,
the company that sold them the loan is
long gone by then.
They,
they,
they're not holding it.
They,
as soon as they got her name on the,
on the dotted line,
they sold it off to a bank in New York
who in turn again chopped it up into
hamburger and sold it probably to you
are a pension fund or who or whatever.
So there's nobody she could complain to
and you know.
Yeah.
That stuff was really depressing.
What was the feeling like of having very
little understanding about finance and
then immersing yourself in it and that
was fascinating.
This is the underlying structure that
our society is run on that our money is
established through like this is,
this is how we,
we sell houses and loans and this is
what we're doing this.
Yeah,
no,
it was,
it was fascinating.
I,
because before that I was mostly
covering like elections,
right?
And again,
if you cover elections,
it's incredibly boring and you never
hear anything of substance and it's not
terribly complicated.
And you know,
one,
one the Democrats says that,
you know,
we want to help the middle class and the
Republicans says we want to protect
family values.
And that's pretty much the extent of the
intellectual challenge in terms of
covering that stuff.
And I always thought to myself,
you know,
politics in America must be a lot more
complicated than this,
right.
There must be some other hidden thing
where it's incredibly complex and
diabolical and,
and you know,
the,
the real machinations of power must be
visible somewhere.
And,
um,
I think that you find that when you,
when you start looking at the,
how Wall Street works,
how money works,
how central banking works,
how,
um,
you know,
how the concentration of wealth works.
Uh,
I mean,
basically the subprime scheme was an
effort to pull the remaining savings out
of the population.
Right?
There just wasn't,
you know,
in the old days,
invest in banks made their money by
lending money to companies who would
build factories and they would make
stuff and sell it around the world and
everybody would make money and never,
you know,
even even the,
the population would,
would,
would benefit from it.
But that manufacturing economy,
it's all gone.
It's overseas.
So you have this financial as the
economy and they have no normal
beneficial.
A way to make money and all their,
all of it can really do is look to see
where is their money and how can we get
it.
And most people had money in their
houses,
right?
Like the,
the accumulated savings of most people.
Whatever was left after the Internet
crash in the nineties,
uh,
was in real estate.
And this was the scam by which they took
the wealth that was left in the pockets
of ordinary people and transferred it to
nine people in Manhattan basically.
I mean,
that's,
that's why you have,
you know,
we told them when we talk about wealth
inequality now,
right,
it being a huge factor that,
you know,
the top 95,
I'm sorry,
the top 1% of the population owns 90% of
the wealth in the country or whatever it
is.
That's a consequence of schemes like
this where they're just there,
they're finding out where people have a
little bit of money and they're
systematically coming up with scams to
move it from there to here.
No consequences,
no with no consequences.
And that was the other part of the,
that that I ended up having to cover
later,
which was,
you know,
the last time they tried something like
this,
like during the s and l crisis,
which was also sort of a giant fraud
scheme also that involved real estate
lending and you know,
but the government after that actually,
you know,
and died at 1800 people,
they put 800 people in jail.
They put a lot of,
you know,
serious,
influential people on the dock after
that.
Uh,
nobody,
nobody went to jail after this stuff.
And there was,
and people think that,
well,
they didn't do anything that was
technically illegal.
No bullshit there.
There was lots of stuff that was,
that was brazenly criminally illegal.
I mean,
they,
they committed fraud on a broad scale.
Uh,
but some of these companies were into
things that were even worse than that.
I mean,
you take HSBC,
HSBC admitted to laundering $850 million
for a pair of central and South American
drug cartels,
uh,
including the Sinaloa cartel,
right.
Which is suspected and thousands of
murders,
like,
and you know,
they,
they admitted to this activity,
they agreed to a deferred prosecution
agreement with the government where
nobody did a day in jail.
No individual had to pull out a dime out
of their own pockets to pay.
The shareholders ponied up one point $9
million,
but some of that was tax deductible,
which means we pay,
we paid some of that fine.
Um,
and uh,
and the only real punishment with any
teeth is that some of the executives had
to partially defer their bonuses for
five years.
Uh,
so that's it.
Laundering $850 million for narco
terrorists gets you a total walk.
Uh,
you know,
that tells you basically everything you
need to know about w do we prosecute
white collar crime in this country?
Basically?
No.
You know,
I mean,
that's the answer ultimately that you
find out.
And there was paperwork that showed they
knew it was from the cartels.
Oh yeah.
They,
if you've,
if you look at the,
the,
the agreement,
uh,
and you can watch that.
There's,
there's a,
there's a video of,
um,
of Loretta Lynch and Lanny Breuer,
cause this was before Laura,
Loretta Lynch was the attorney general,
but she was,
um,
uh,
she was basically the head of this deal.
Um,
they talked about the fact that the HSBC
branches,
because most of this was done in Mexico.
Um,
uh,
h Max,
which was the subsidiary company.
They had special teller windows built,
uh,
to fit cashboxes that the drug cartels
were bringing in to the bank.
Uh,
so basically you've seen the,
seen the seen in scarface for the guys
come in with duffle bags with cash to
the bank.
Right.
And you know,
that's like a montage,
you know,
there's that,
that song,
I forget what song it is,
the background,
same thing.
These guys would come into the bank,
they would slide in these boxes of cash,
one after the other,
and that's admitted activity.
The bank signed off on this.
They,
you know,
it's not like they're contesting it.
They're not saying,
we neither admit nor deny.
It's,
it's part of the deal.
Uh,
so,
and,
and they agreed to the amount,
everything.
So,
um,
yeah,
it was a one point $9 billion
settlement.
But you know,
it,
it's not like it came out of the pockets
of the people who did it.
And it's not like any of the people who
did it are in jail.
It's just,
you know,
a thing that happened and you know,
that's five weeks of profit for the
bank.
So what,
what the fuck?
They don't care.
Right.
Did you see the documentary inside job?
Ah,
Yup.
We've covered a lot of the same
territory.
That's exactly,
yeah.
That was a sobering documentary where
they're talking to the very people that
caused the financial crisis and,
and realizing that these people were
economics professors that eventually got
these jobs,
really lucrative jobs with banks and how
they finagle this system and made it so
it looked like these things were
appropriate.
Yeah,
no,
I talked to some of the,
some of the things that they invented
that made this,
the crash possible sounded like good
ideas.
Like they,
they came up with this thing called the
credit default swap.
Right.
And I won't bore you with what that is
exactly,
but basically it's a kind of insurance,
uh,
where,
it's,
it's basically a bet.
It's hard to explain.
Um,
but it's a way of,
of quasi I ensuring a product,
um,
without having to pony up a lot of
money.
Uh,
and the,
it's called the derivative,
right?
Uh,
and these instruments are completely
unregulated.
Um,
kind of put the socratic default swap
is,
is like,
uh,
you and I betting on whether or not a
third person's house is going to a burn
in a fire,
right?
Like the old school insurance said that
it had to be your house in order for you
to get insurance on it.
Um,
this new form of [inaudible] insurance
said that too,
totally disinterested parties could have
an interest in a,
in a,
in a third thing that happens.
So it's basically gambling.
Uh,
and um,
on the one hand,
it allowed people to create a whole lot
of capital,
which allowed them to lend more money,
which theoretically allowed people to
buy more houses.
But in reality,
it just created the system where all
these people had bets that were back and
forth on,
on all these properties.
So that's one of the reasons why the,
when the crash happened,
when,
when all those mortgages started to
fail,
it wasn't just the failures of those
properties.
It was all these people who are betting
on whether or not these people could,
could pay their mortgages.
They started to lose money and then
there were people who had bets on that.
He started to lose money and it's like
this cascading whirlpool of shit that
happened.
And um,
again,
it just,
it started out as an idea to just create
more money to lend to lend.
And it turned into this nightmare,
a mechanical scenario that just,
that created losses.
Uh,
you know,
in this almost apocalyptic fashion.
And a lot of them had no idea,
but that,
that was going to be the eventuality.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's definitely crazy stuff.
As a person who didn't really follow
finance before,
how much has that affected your life
down?
Like the way you look at things?
I definitely pay a lot more attention to
the fine print.
Uh,
when I enter into any financial
contract,
um,
I think about where I do my banking.
Uh,
but the reality is you just don't have a
whole lot of choice in this country
anyway.
I mean,
it's like everything else.
There's only a few companies left.
Um,
so almost every bank,
uh,
that's out there where you can have a
bank account and a mortgage is,
is a bank that I've written about
something massive scandal,
uh,
before.
So,
uh,
that,
that's,
that's a problem.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I worry about it all the time and I have
friends in finance who call me and they,
they tell me that,
you know,
that the things that are incredibly
unsafe and that this,
that,
and the other could,
could,
could happen.
And so I have an anxiety level about
things that I never had before.
But um,
apart from that,
yeah,
I mean,
that's a natural consequence of,
of having to spend seven years looking
at all these horror stories.
It's crazy.
You spent that much time on it.
Do you see any other bubbles coming up?
Yeah,
people talk about that all the time.
Um,
there's a lot of,
um,
a lot of negative press about subprime
auto loans for instance,
which is,
uh,
it's not exactly the same but it's a
similar thing.
I mean the same basic scam of taking
loans,
chopping them up and then repackaging
them as something that's more valuable
than the original loan.
You can do that with anything,
any kind of credit.
You can do that with credit cards.
You can do it with aircraft loans,
you can do it with,
with car loans,
with home mortgages.
Um,
and so the,
the mechanism of taking things that are,
are toxic and risky and making them look
like aaa is still,
uh,
it's still part of the economy and um,
it's everywhere.
The plus side of that is that there is
more credit available.
Uh,
you know,
almost anybody can get a credit card or
even if you've had screwed up credit,
you can get a car,
you know,
I mean,
there's this is this put us in this
endless cycle of buildup,
bubble collapse,
build up,
rebounding,
collapse again.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I think that's,
that's,
that's why you have to be nervous about
the,
you know,
the skyrocketing stock exchange because
we've had a fine,
yeah.
I mean,
you should be.
Right.
Do you have,
what are you heavily invested in?
I've got some in there.
I just did when,
when the whole,
you know,
when trump was saying the economy's
never been better,
look at the stock market stock markets,
killing it all these days,
and then it'll have a bad day and you're
like,
well,
okay,
well I thought we were doing great.
Like what's going on with his bad day?
Can you not control these bad days?
Right?
Like what's happening here?
Right.
If you're,
if you're in control of the good days,
you're also in control of the bad days.
Right?
Yeah,
of course.
Of course.
It just,
it seems,
it seems super suspicious.
Yeah.
And,
and in the old days,
you'd have a lot of confidence that,
well,
the stock market always eventually goes
up.
So yeah,
there's going to be bad days,
but it'll,
it'll go back up.
But the problem is the underlying
economy in America just isn't all that
hot.
You know,
like we're like,
what do we really make in this country?
What,
wha where's the floor?
Right?
Like we have,
we have some industries that sorta
perform well,
but if,
you know,
periodically we go through these bubbles
that are based on nothing more than
enthusiasm.
Uh,
you know,
in the nineties it was the,
the tech bubble,
right?
Where people like Alan Greenspan would
say things like,
well,
we have a new paradigm and economics,
right?
So,
um,
it doesn't matter whether a company
hasn't shown any ability to make money
or,
um,
you know,
has no reasonable profit and loss
statements.
It's just,
if it's a good idea,
the stock is sound and everybody should
invest in it and the stock market is
going to continually go up,
go up.
So don't worry about it.
Of course that doesn't happen and
everybody blows.
It blows up.
Everybody loses their shirt.
But what,
what do they do?
The Fed,
lowered interest rates basically allows
Wall Street to recapitalize,
drink itself sober,
and they plunge into the next,
the next madness,
which is mortgages.
And once again,
you have Alan Greenspan saying,
hey,
you know,
real estate is a great bet.
It's,
you know,
it's going to continually ascend.
People should use their homes as ATM
machines.
You know,
you should,
you should consider refinancing your
house so that you can get a little bit
of extra cash.
And,
and this,
this,
this was actually the message they sent
to America and it again,
it creates this artificial mania where
the economy's stoked artificially,
uh,
two gigantic dimensions,
but it's not based on anything.
And so when,
when it,
and it crashes,
when you finally get like any scheme,
you know,
it depends.
It depends on more new investors coming
in and old investors leaving,
right?
So there's always going to be that
moment when suddenly we don't have as
many new ones and old ones.
And the instant that happens,
it all goes,
Kaboom.
Right?
And that's what happened with,
with,
uh,
the subprime market.
There was a moment in time where the,
they just couldn't keep it going
anymore.
They couldn't find any more new soccer's
the to get to,
to sell mortgages to and the mania ended
and an all went splat and then it was
amplified by the fact that we have this
system now of people betting on credit,
uh,
that is legal,
um,
which creates more losses out of at a
thin air.
So yeah,
I'm terrified every time I see this,
the,
the stock market go up.
What's it based on?
Is it based on our economy actually
doing well?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
You know,
um,
I'm sorry.
I look like I'm scaring you a little
bit.
Definitely a scary thing,
but I think that's good.
I think I need to be scared.
I,
I tend to take these things and just,
you know,
I have financial advisors.
I like let them handle money.
When I hear things like this,
I just go,
oh,
Jesus.
Well,
I get terrified when I hear about really
smart people getting scammed.
Like yesterday we were talking about,
uh,
theranose.
Do you know that a blood testing company
that turned out to be total horse shit?
No,
I didn't hear about this.
Oh,
it's a great story.
It's a,
it's a story of one of those things
where you,
you find someone who you hope exists and
you build them up.
There was this woman,
she looked like Steve Jobs.
She wore a black turtle neck and every
photo and uh,
she was,
uh,
the,
the richest ever self made woman.
She was worth $4 billion.
She had built this company called the
rhinos right out of college.
She was like 19 when she started the
company.
It was a blood testing company that just
required a small prick of your blood to
do complicated blood analysis for
diseases and things along those lines.
It turns out it didn't work at all.
And uh,
Dave faked a bunch of shit.
God spread fraud.
A lot of people got their blood tested.
It turned out to be,
you know,
they,
they were at risk for all these diseases
and uh,
Warren Buffet have invested $100
million.
I think at one 25,
uh,
Betsy Devos,
more than a hundred million dollars,
like all these super wealthy people get
scammed.
Wow.
Yeah.
When you find out that really wealthy
people,
right,
that do this for a living,
Warren Buffet does that for a living
that he can get scammed out of $125
million.
Right?
Yeah.
And,
and,
and Warren Buffett,
his,
his mantra is supposed to be picking
the,
the absolute longterm investment,
right?
So it's not,
he's not like a Stevie Cohen type who
just looks at the tape and tries to time
it just right.
So you can make an investment for 10
seconds and come out with,
with,
uh,
you know,
if he,
if he's investing in a company and,
uh,
and even he can be fooled.
That's,
that's pretty terrible.
But look at Enron.
I mean,
and run was,
was another example of the world's best
financial analysts were looking at this
company for a decade,
and the,
the results were completely ridiculous.
Like,
it should have been obvious to any lay
person that,
that,
uh,
these profit numbers couldn't possibly
be real.
Uh,
and it wasn't until,
uh,
one of those guys,
I think it was jim chain,
this,
it was sort of a famous short seller,
um,
sort of said,
hey,
wait a minute,
that there's something up here.
Um,
but people continually invested in these
companies and there's just not a whole
lot of oversight that goes on,
um,
uh,
with,
with Wall Street.
And I think that's,
that's a major lesson of,
of,
uh,
you know,
the last 20 years is that,
is that there's just not a lot of eyes
on,
on crime in this area.
Another example is,
uh,
I'm sorry,
the WHO's the guy scammed all the rich
people I made off.
Yeah.
I was going to bring him up.
He's the most egregious example,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
there are other,
there are other people who did similar
things.
Um,
but this guy didn't even make
investments.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like he,
he was literally just sort of taking
money and you know,
when someone cashed out,
he would,
you know,
it was,
it was like,
uh,
who's that little girl t little t,
little t.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just like throwing,
he had a big pile of cash and you know,
he would,
he would take some men and throw some
out.
But if the SEC had had at any time,
just looked at his books and said,
what are you invested in?
Um,
it all would have,
you know,
that whole house of cards would have
fallen and invest in anything.
No,
he wasn't,
he wasn't making trades,
he wasn't doing anything,
you know.
And,
and there were a bunch of stories like
this.
Uh,
there's a great book called the octopus,
which is about as somebody who did a
made off like scam and other hedge fund,
um,
where,
same thing,
they weren't really making trades.
They were just sort of creating phony
profit and loss statements and,
and,
and creating records that look like
trades.
Uh,
they could,
they could tell their investors about,
but they weren't actually doing
anything.
So if anybody,
any expert at any time had just poke
their nose into this person's books,
they would have seen it in 10 seconds.
That's the,
I mean,
that's the amazing thing about this.
Um,
you know,
not,
not to get back to,
you know,
my,
my drug dealing book,
but this is one of the things that he
says,
which is that,
you know,
you can be in a,
an a poor black neighborhood and a
couple of kids will be on a cell phone
and talking about selling $10 worth of
weed and there'll be picked up by cops,
you know,
within 20 minutes or something like
that.
Meanwhile,
you know,
somebody like,
uh,
you know,
Bernie madoff can commit hundred million
dollar frauds year after year after year
and not even do any,
take any effort to try to cover it up
all that well and get away with it.
Well,
Bernie's big crime was that he ripped
off rich people.
Yeah,
absolutely.
If he had done the exact same thing to
poor p,
well what he did was just,
it was just too easy to call what he did
a crime versus what you were talking
about with these financial institutions.
Right?
Yeah.
If he,
if he had lawn,
if he had laundered it through a
slightly more legitimate process,
he would have gotten out fine.
But the,
one of the things that a lot of these
guys,
these scam artists get into it thinking
that they're actually gonna be real
hedge funds.
Um,
and that they,
they have some stock pigging system
that's actually going to make all their
clients Moni.
And one of the things they find out is
that a,
they suck.
They,
they,
they're not outperforming the market and
they're not that smart but be that their
clients can't tell if they just make up
the numbers.
So there,
there are a number of cases of people
who start out trying to be legitimate
and trying to be real,
real investment advisors,
but they just ended up turning into
Bernie madoff types because it's just
easy.
There's no there,
there,
there aren't that many people watching
for it.
And uh,
you know that that's kind of scary too.
Well,
it seems like there's so many people
doing it.
How could there be enough people
watching it?
Right?
Think about how many investment firms
there are and how many different people
that are involved in trading.
How could anybody be watching all of it,
right?
Yeah.
No,
they're there.
But the evens even so even if you take
that into consideration,
then the,
then the number of eyes that are,
that are on this world is,
is ridiculously low.
Like take,
take Aig.
Aig was one of the world's largest,
uh,
companies that before,
before it crashed,
it had like 180,000 employees.
Um,
it was,
it took advantage of this.
We are loophole that allows financial
companies to essentially choose their
own regulator.
Um,
so because,
because aig had a thrift or a savings
and loan,
that's basically the same thing.
They chose to be regulated by the Ots,
which is the office of thrift
supervision,
which is this tiny,
tiny little,
um,
uh,
you know,
office in Washington that overseas
basically savings and loan operations.
And in,
in the Ots,
this is,
this is actually true.
The,
they had exactly one insurance expert on
staff.
So essentially what the world's largest
insurance company was being regulated by
a government office that only had one
person who really understood insurance
and,
and even,
and even that person wouldn't have
understood the,
the part of the company that blew up,
which was essentially an investment bank
within the insurance company that was
creating these sort of highly advanced
sort of derivative operations,
um,
that know that they just would not have
been able to understand that stuff.
So
the government just does not place a lot
of resources into,
you know,
keeping an eye on even the most basic
things.
And when you compare that to law
enforcement and other areas,
you know,
is how many,
how many people do we have,
you know,
worrying about bank bank robberies in
this country or,
or drugs,
right.
Or how many people are,
are being watched because their
marijuana dealers in other states.
I mean it,
it dwarfs the number of people who are
watching for economic crimes.
Yeah.
One person,
I just love the,
the name of it.
Office of thrift supervision.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm not even sure it exists anymore.
I think it was,
it was merged into some other,
uh,
cause there used to be the OCC officer
of the comptroller of the currency and I
think they created a new regulator out
out of all of that after the crash.
But,
um,
but yeah,
Aig shows it's regulator and it's
regulator,
you know,
was totally overmatched,
didn't,
couldn't understand shit.
And that's one of the reasons why the
company blew up.
The company also bill up because it was
run by insurance people who didn't
understand it.
I do,
is basically Wall Street's bookie,
all these people were betting all of
these investment banks were betting on
whether or not mortgages we're going to
fail or not.
And Aig was selling the product that
they could use,
uh,
to make those bets essentially.
Or there were taking on insurance on,
on packets of mortgages.
So if they exploded,
you would get a payout,
right?
Uh,
it was,
it's like,
it's like buying an insurance policy on
your neighbor's house.
If it goes up in flames,
you get paid,
you get paid.
Aig was selling a product that allowed
banks essentially to buy insurance on,
on houses,
on mortgages.
And if the,
if people foreclosed,
if the mortgage is failed or pools of
mortgages failed,
uh,
if you,
if you bought that kind of insurance,
you got these huge payouts.
So people were betting against mortgages
basically.
And Aig was taking all this book and,
but the,
the heads of the company were old school
insurance executives and just didn't
understand this sort of new fangled,
um,
complicated form of insurance.
And so they would look at the numbers
that they were being given.
And even they didn't get it.
They didn't,
they didn't understand how,
how exposed they were.
And so when all of the bet started going
the wrong way,
suddenly they're being asked to pay out
billions of dollars and they're like,
well,
wait,
where is this coming from?
So,
so even the companies were kind of
clueless about the shit that was going
on.
It turns out,
well,
listen,
man,
if it wasn't for you,
dummies like me would not understand why
we should be scared.
Like everybody was scared.
But reading your,
your articles about it,
maybe understand why.
And I think that's a,
the way he described it as great,
that you translated this stuff.
You actually worked at as trash as a
translator.
And,
uh,
I appreciate your work,
man.
Oh,
thank you so much for him to have been a
huge fan forever.
I'm looking forward to seeing your
special,
I mean,
you have,
uh,
yeah,
it's going to come out sometime around
September.
I think that's when they're gonna
release it.
Excellent.
Thank you,
man.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you,
Matt.
Thanks for coming on,
man.
Thank you very much,
Matt.
Taibbi ladies and gentlemen.
[inaudible].